welcome to Dr Brian King's Rocking New
Year's Eve with with two of my good
friends Max tegmark Eric Weinstein guys
I can't thank you enough for joining us
today we're going to have a fun
conversation to end it's really been
like a fun year for everybody right
nothing bad has happened this year uh
where are you guys same old same old
where are you guys weathering weathering
the storm that has been 2020 Max where
are you currently joining us from I am
home in the great Metropolis of
Winchester Mass assetts ah Winchester
and Eric where are you joining us from
today an undisclosed location somewhere
in Los
Angeles those are the scariest ones of
all when I was a kid and New Year's Eve
we'd watch uh pro wrestling you know
which is maybe a moniker I don't know
how how professional you need to be but
anyway it would always be the scariest
wrestlers were from Parts Unknown like
they don't know where like the guy
didn't put it on his resume where he's
from uh well the The Undertaker can't be
from Middlebury Connecticut
that's right he has a small candle shop
and uh he does some scrimshaw in there
uh but uh boys we are here you guys were
last gracing my presence this summer
together at least although you were
separated in time when my channel
partnered with PBS space time Studios
Matt odow and his team on a discussion
of theories of everything and we had two
live streams over the summer I'll put
links to those in the uh in the notes
box below but since then we you both
have been involved in some really
interesting kind of side hustles I I
think and uh I think the the audience
would be appreciative if we could talk
about how things have gone since that
summertime Suare pair of sarees where I
should say you two were not on the
screen at the same time but uh but so
today it was the chance for for three
men to enter and then no no there'll
only be all three of us will exit
because we have New Year's Eve plans
tonight um max what have you been up to
since the Summer's Theory of Everything
uh
shindy well aside for from uh some
remote teaching torturing MIT freshmen
with physics I've been um spending a lot
of time on U this attempt to make our
news a little bit
less lousy uh I think uh we have such
amazing opportunities to do great things
as a species as long as we actually have
a clear idea of what's actually going on
I think um things have gotten pretty uh
notably worse on that front in in recent
years as uh partly because uh on media
has gone online and put so many
traditional journalists out ofit out of
work and even more importantly because
just machine learning algorithms have
started to create these filter Bubbles
and new tools for manipulating people to
be really quite poorly informed of
what's happening it's the basis of doing
good things in science is always step
one you know figure out where you are
that's what I want to help and Eric what
about you uh this has been a very
peaceful season I'm sure uh in your
corner of America what have you been
thinking about ruminating on well in
part I've been trying to get past the
election I actually because I've been
politically active I'm very concerned as
Max seems to be about the news but also
the way the meta news and our
integration into the news is working and
I'm particularly distressed about the
attempt to control intellectual thought
as if it is
subversive uh you know undermining of of
the country with everyone picking on
either Russia or China or some nefarious
group the Trump family and the idea
being that if we will just trust um you
know the Washington Post or Dr fouchy or
Mitch McConnell everything will be okay
and I don't and I don't trust YouTube
and I don't trust Google I don't trust
things that I can't talk about and so
I'm particularly distressed about the
idea that we're entering an era in which
things are so serious that we have the
we have an obligation to get people who
disagree with consensus off the air
because they are subversive because I
don't know how we make Pro if we can't
tell the difference between cranks
Mavericks heterodox thinkers Geniuses
and all of that stuff we are toast and
it's you know imagine if we said um that
we ma Max tegmark overnight can't show
up to his office at MIT because in fact
um he's he's producing harmful
conversations I I just can't imagine
that all of our institutions other than
Trader Joe's and maybe coinbase have
capitulated I'm so glad to hear you say
this actually it's quite refreshing
because um Richard fan you know is one
of my superheroes like to say that the
essence of science is don't trust
anybody you know not even yourself and
your own your own your own prejudice is
right and uh science had to fight really
really hard to get this ability to to
start challenging everybody if Galileo
tweeted that hey the sun is actually not
revolving around the
earth and then the pope fact Checkers
say fact check this violates Community
guidelines it's actually the Sun going
around the earth that would not have
gone so great and in fact things the
1600s version of that kind of happened
to Galileo we fought so hard against for
this Freedom as scientists to have
everybody count equally and yet here we
are now you know in if you're in China
and there is a a government that tells
you this is what the truth is if you're
in North Korea you have a government
that tells you what the truth is and and
now somehow it's a good idea to try to
have I think there's there a lot of a
lot of good intent behind the
factchecking today um but if you say
that there's some committee at some big
corporation that has a monopoly of
what's saying what's true that's exactly
the opposite of what we've learned from
science all these times in in science
there is no we acknowledge that it's
hard to figure out what the truth is
right that's why we didn't want the pope
to say it or or Kim Jong-un my papers
get refereed by random other scientists
right not by some appointed uh committee
on at a
company right and I think that you know
in some ways and yet it moves is the
original harmful
conversation uh you can imagine if the
pope put a little tagline under it
saying this claim is disputed uh by
experts everywhere the key thing is
understanding the the difference between
Mavericks cranks and what I've called
knars and of course Mac because you're
Swedish you'll appreciate the word Arc
which is crank spelled backwards and
they they sit at the center of our
establishment and they do cranky things
from the chairs of greatest
respectability and it's very important
to me that karky behavior um be
distinguished from cranky Behavior be
distinguished from heterodox behavior
and I wanted to plug Max's effort
fqxi which is an attempt at non- cranky
heterodox thinking in physics and now
Beyond and it's the leading organiz a
sort of analogous to The Institute for
New Economic thinking in the economics
field of course the perimeter Institute
was founded in the Santa Fe Institute
was founded in this regard this has a
long tradition and I really think that
even though we may be doing this on
YouTube and things YouTube needs to butt
the hell out of the idea of we know what
reality is and we'll let you uh post
about it or not as we see fit because
that's just not that's going to grind
Society to a halt and we're not having
it yeah and if it were so easy to
actually find out the truth
science would be done all of us
scientists should be fired we could go
home right just have some government
officials or corporate officials saying
this is true this is false right this is
why we need science in the first we we
can consult the truth and safety the
trust and Safety Committee and and and
they can finish it off we don't need the
AI to tell us the the secrets so uh
speaking of YouTube some of us make our
living from you no I'm just kidding I I
don't Gavin Newsome my boss if you're
listening out there I'm uh hard at work
as you can tell every day uh but these
podcasts do uh and Gavin Nome Bite Me Oh
I me seriously YouTube bite me we we we
we've got to stop looking at our
incentive structures yes they can shut
us all down tomorrow let's stop cow
Towing and and graveling in front of
people who don't deserve it should we
talk some science yeah let's get into
that but first I want to ask you
something uh frivolous which is that I
promised I swore Eric that if anyone
came out of this pandemic with a
six-pack I would kill them okay and you
my friend have done that you've you've
you've dropped serious I said I dropped
five pounds from my double chin to my
stomach but you have come out with a
sixpack I wonder was this part of your
New Year's resolution last year and what
is your New Year's resolution each one
of you guys this year I think they're
very important to make New Year's
resolutions Eric what is was yours last
year what's yours for
2021 um I forgot what mine was for last
year I think for for
um I'm going to push out geometric Unity
as uh in written form wow okay you heard
it there here first ladies and gentlemen
I am this is the first time I've said
that too and I am uh going to provide
whatever meager means of support I can
provide to do that Max amilon you're
worth Max a million dollar I remember
when I met you I said is your name Max
amillion you said I'm not a millionaire
yet so is 2021 the year you become a
millionaire and get some of that Elon
Musk Quan or what do you what do you
want to do in 2021 you do so many things
so well so so interesting you you just
suck the juices out of life what do you
have plans for in plan uh for
2021 money is never something I've
particularly cared about I have two new
New Year resolutions uh one is to
um take the improve the news project
which I mentioned uh and make it way
better I I have a lot of ideas and a lot
of people have sent me a lot of ideas
for um
um doing something much better than the
sort of factchecking that we were
whining about here which is much more
science inspired and make it easier for
people to actually find out what's going
on that's my nights and weekends job and
then my day job is to do some really
awesome uh research at the interface of
artificial intelligence and physics I'm
so fortunate to have an amazing group of
of uh students and other colleagues to
work with an MIT and U so I I was
sitting yesterday looking at all these
project ideas and ranking them and and
just feeling so excited and wishing that
2021 would be much longer than 365
days well we're going to talk a lot
about time as we uh continue here first
of all I'm going to start taking some
questions from the audience and I think
well so there are people asking what
does Max think about geometric Unity
there are people asking what does Eric
think about Max's mathematical universe
I am willing to go there if you guys are
but that wasn't the pretext in which I
tricked I mean invited you guys to come
on uh but so but but I think it's
interesting to get a status report maybe
on The Theory of Everything side and
then we'll turn to Power of AI in
physics and different projects that you
and I are interested in Eric and and Max
uh so first of all what are you guys
thinking about let's just say your own
field your own projects and then what if
you don't want to comment on the other's
project at least the value of having
multiple projects and I'll say this very
lovingly but to my friend Sabine
hossenfelder who's got a wonderful
channel uh of hers and she's really
amped it up and upped her game and she's
one of my uh kind of Role Models I'm
trying to look up to she has said that
you know she basically doesn't have time
to think about these new theories of
everything whether it's it's it's Eric's
or Steven Wolfram who's been on the show
or Garrett Ley or even maybe Max tegmark
so what do you think though of the value
of pursuing alternatives to the dominant
Paradigm which is I would say probably
String Theory right now for in terms of
a candidate Theory of Everything Max you
go first what's your what are your
current thoughts on theories of
everything other than your
own I I think it's I applaud people
pursuing the full spectrum of of
theories as I said earlier if it were so
easy to know the truth we wouldn't need
science we'd be done right and uh it's
very unhealthy to have an intellectual
monoculture where everybody is looking
under the the same lamp post that's not
the best search algorithm to find your
keys or The Theory of Everything um so
in fact my main uh Al meta algorithm as
a scientist which has served me
surprisingly well is that if I noticed
that the whole herd was going in this
direction and I would usually go in a
different direction look there because
you never become the first to find
something if you're just following
others right and Eric what do you think
about not only uh you know the value of
gu or the status of gu for example oh I
was going to I thought I was going to do
Max and Max was going to do me oh yeah
Max do you want well Max Max do you want
to comment on alternative theories of
everything well I think
uh if you I think um maybe for the
benefit since we don't have time to get
into something super detailed and I
still haven't had a chance to read the
paper that you now officially pledged
you're going to write next year maybe
you could just very Briefly summarize a
core an idea or or a theme for the
benefit also of our readers and then
they can comment on that
sure um well then let me go first and
then then um Brian call take Max and
I'll try to integrate something in to
tee it up for him to spike uh to dunk on
me
rather so the first thing I would say is
that I don't think Sabina is being
truthful um and I think that she's being
polite
uh she is a ferocious and fierce uh uh
friend of physics uh who cares very much
about the honesty of the subject but
she's personally really saying something
else which I think we should say that
she doesn't believe that these theories
are worthy of her time because they
don't have a certain Gena that suggests
that they are effectively correct and
the cost of exploring them seems high so
I I want to not take suben uh particular
gift of her diplomacy uh and lean too
heavily on it she has the time to record
music videos she just doesn't think that
this crop smells good enough in order to
dig into it is what I really think is
going on and I think that that's really
common because what's really suffusing
the field is a sense of hopelessness
where we don't really believe that
anybody is on the verge of the theory of
everything in the way that derck and
Einstein were pushing things for forward
at the beginning of the 20th century now
I also disagree I don't think that's
where we are I think we've been stalled
out for almost 50 years in a certain
sense not in others I don't think that
string theory is still the leading
candidate or if it is it's only because
it's greatly diminished and nothing else
has taken its place I think Max's um
mathematical universe is an interesting
issue I I I I've come at it from a
different way so I I've never actually
had this conversation with Max we can
find out whether we dovetail on this but
I I say sometimes that um The Theory of
Everything or fundamental physics is
really the one place that we have where
we think that the map may be the
territory and that's a little bit of the
way in which I interpret um the special
nature of the theory of everything and
and somewhat the lens through which I
understand Max's ideas which is that the
math is the reality not that the math
models the reality then there's some
extra stuff which says that all math is
effectively created in in a physical
instantiation in some sense on on that I
will remain silent because it's only
this sector that I have any direct
tangible experience with I think that
that's quite possibly the truth we may
be looking at things that where the map
and the territory are not distinct like
Greenland is the map of
Greenland
um as for GU just to be quite clear
about it um my take is that we haven't
owned up to the fact that the final step
is different than all the previous ones
and is conceptually much harder and so
my attempt was to say can we drag three
generations of chyal
Fons uh with the particular sorts of
interactions that we see plausibly from
a radically simplified
hypothesis so that we get everything
emergently we don't get something from
nothing but we get something from almost
nothing this is sort of inverse to the
Garrett Lei method where what you do is
you take the most complicated simple
object in the universe that sounds like
a contradiction but isn't and then you
find the Baroque complexity of our world
inside it using something like E8 what I
do is I start with four degrees of
freedom and I say Einstein made it a
very interesting mistake and a beautiful
one which is that he started with the
concept of SpaceTime and that SpaceTime
is the picking out of a particular
system of rulers and protractors
responding to the matter on the
four-dimensional EXT extended structure
called a manifold but that what we
should be looking at is the original
four degrees of freedom the protospace
time together with all possible rulers
and protractors and that creates a
14-dimensional world called a bundle of
metrics and that each individual metric
is like a periscope going between the
four-dimensional world and its 14
dimensional emergent extension and just
the way if you poke your Periscope up in
the AR Arctic and you see a polar bear
hunting a seal you're receiving the
image down below inside your submarine
and what we are currently experiencing
in my understanding is that we are in a
14-dimensional
space looking at it from a
four-dimensional space via the metric
which is the pullback is what we would
call a pullback it's the agent of
pulling back the data from 14 to 4 and
that the 10 dimensions of uh rulers and
protractors that Einstein put his 10
coupled differential equations are in
fact the same 10 Dimensions that would
crop up in Grand unified theory of the
so 10 or spin 10 variety or more
important the P Salam Theory which is
Spin Six cross Spin 4 you take 10
dimensions and you break it into sort of
two pieces if you will and that that
arises naturally from the way in which
the 10 rulers and protractors emerge
from the 31 components and to dovetail
the two Brian you asked me before
whether Wolfram and I had a connection I
think Max and I actually have a much
richer connection than wolf and I have I
would say that the
41322 uh 31 and 04 sectors all exist but
that we'll never meet them because we
can't get to them and it may be that we
are in anthropic sectors that support
life I also believe there are only two
generations Max not three the third one
is an impostor that would unify
differently with particles that we
haven't seen um and that the world is
not actually chyal but only emerg ently
chyal and in that uh light gra in Low
Gravity environments it appears to be
chyal but if we were near a black hole
or the beginning of the universe we
would suddenly see a lot of matter that
now appears dark coupled to the matter
that we
are I take it you have it's not a
question of whether you've read the
paper I released an episode um on
geometric Unity with video from the
Oxford lecture and that that's sort of a
a quick fly over if you want to if you
want to start uh hunting fish in a
barrel
yeah you'll be proud of me for actually
having watched this video this morning
even to get it fresh in my my memory
here it's very interesting stuff I I I
really agree with um with what you with
um what you said there in that there I
don't see any any
particular disagree incompatibility
between what you're saying and and what
I'm saying U first of all
um it it's it's very striking that even
though you did talk about a polar bear
you know that was an example and and
really was reaching out to my Swedish
Brethren every exactly everything you
everything you said about uh the theory
itself was
mathematical and um it's interesting as
well if you talk to string theorists or
Loop quantum gravity fans you know
theories are utterly mathematical as
well there's really
no bleeding Contender I would say on the
market for theory of everything right
now which is not mathematical so it uh
it's not so shocking in that context to
talk about the idea that maybe the
ultimate theory is mathematical and and
then another another very strong
commonality is you you said yourself
here right that it's pretty natural in
your theory that the ultimate physical
reality that exists is bigger than the
part that we actually have access to and
can see and I I find it kind of
emotionally amusing that so many people
get all twisted up about this and all
stressed out about the idea that there
could be things that actually exist
physically that we can't access it seems
so arrogant to me I mean if you're an
ostrich and you stick your head in the
sand should you really be arguing to
yourself that if I can't see something
then it somehow has no moral right to
exist I mean if you start the other way
around with a just a premise that there
is some stuff that exists
physically why should we be so arrogant
as to think that it's all going to be
accessible to us uh it seems like um a
kind of hubristic uh starting point the
um so I'm very interested in in
uh when you finish the technical paper
seeing more about how the details
actually come out because the devils are
always devil is always in the details as
as know let me say maybe two more things
philosophically that sort of give a
grounding I think one of the reasons
that we have failed to unify
physics um very successfully I mean
obviously we had Maxwell and then
glashow uh georgei GL glasow um winber
and Salam those are the great
unifications that we've had to date in a
certain sense but I think that part of
what's going on is is that we are
unifying into an uh intended structure
um and that the structures that we will
end up unifying into are actually
tensions between structures so for
example um my guess is that two of the
four main equations if we go field by
field uh will will unify into one
equation the durac and the Einstein
field equations whatever succeeds them I
have in one equation and uh the Yang
Mills and the equation governing the
higs field uh which we would call a
modified Klein Gordon equation would
modifi would uh unify into a different
one and then one of those two unific
ations would effectively be the square
root of the other the other is that
replacing SpaceTime by a pair of spaces
rather than a single space um so in in
essence things unify into into Pairs and
there are tensions within the pairs but
one of the things we've done in our
radical reductionist Heyday um before
any of us were born was to try to unify
things too simply into a
single uh structure that is not capable
of supporting the weight of what we know
so I I claim that there will effectively
be two equations one of which will be
the square root of the other there will
be two spaces that replace one single
unified SpaceTime and that weirdly we've
got everything slightly wrong if we had
it wildly wrong we would figure out that
we had it wildly wrong and if we had it
absolutely right we'd be done and so
weirdly we're sort of slightly wrong
about everything including three
generations it strikes me that you don't
Max have an initial recoil how can that
how can there not be three generations
or how can matter not be uh kyal or how
can how can SpaceTime be dispensed with
uh those are the things that I was
expecting to to have to look I if I've
learned anything as a scientist again
it's to have a very open mind and be
humble as we talked about earlier we
need to be about everything the it's
it's easier to do when you're 10e tall
and good-look but I get your point it's
it's incred guilty as charged it's
incredibly hard to
um take an equ a simple mathematical
Theory and predict what is it going to
feel like to observers who live in that
world right yeah in uh in the G case of
what Galileo did it was so the
correspondence was so direct that it was
easy you you said here's a point in the
mathematical and ukian space and it
corresponds the position of my Apple
that's moving uh
whereas um already when you got to
Einstein it
was super hard The Genius of Einstein
wasn't that he would was the first
person who was able to write down the
equations of special relativity right
which a
relatively but that he was able to
understand what it would feel like to
live in a world governed by those
equations it would feel like time slowed
down you went fast then you got shorter
and other weird things uh in general
relativity it was even harder right it
wasn't Einstein who invented reman
geometry but he he was the one again who
was able to translate the math into pred
physical predictions and realize that it
actually made sense quantum mechanics
has taken us yet another level up where
we've had the equations now we've had
the Shing your equation now for almost a
century and our colleagues are still
arguing about what it means exactly so
that's exactly why I I do not allow
myself to recoil when someone puts out
some equations where it's not obvious
how that's exactly going to match
reality
because that is exactly the thing we've
learned so hard yeah I want to ask just
a related question to that I've had a
conversation with uh Paul steinhardt
who's a the Einstein professor of
natural science at a place called
Princeton University I know Max knows
him well they were colleagues together
before they both jump ship from a
certain ivy league institution that I
won't name because I have good friends
and good colleagues there but um but I
want to talk about a conversation I had
with Paul and he said he didn't know if
he could come up with things like
inflation or e pyrotic universe or
things like that in the age of social
media in that uh you know as soon as he
might have some tentative idea as you
know Eric described to me once you know
we were sitting in my office here in UC
San Diego and he's writing on the CH
like what did Einstein think in 1914
1915 1916 finally 1917 you know it
evolved and numbers changed the equation
changed maybe the meaning didn't
fundamentally change but in an era of
social media by the way I'm going to
take one quick break to remind people
that carpel tunnel syndrome kills 750
million people every year in America
alone so exercise your finger hit the
like button if you're enjoying this a
thumbs up on on Facebook or YouTube hit
the Subscribe button I put links to
Max's YouTube channel which needs some
love Max uh you've got about a th
subscribers we're going to amp that up
right now uh subscribe to Weinstein's
Channel as well I put those in there the
portal subscribe to Dr Brian King's
Channel if you like conversations like
this in the age of social media where
you have sensors in a certain sense uh
that have cell phones instead of uh
instead of you know swords what do you
think is the probability that you guys
could have and come out with theories or
new models can come out uh because
necessarily you guys are theoretically
inclined I'm experimentally inclined we
don't really put out results until you
know it takes years to make an
experiment but but were you guys making
theories or making conjectures about
philosophy and the nature of reality how
has the impact of social media stifled
you if it has um or does it stifle
creativity of young people in particular
Max we'll start with you and then we'll
go to
Eric
well I think it's always been rough
throughout human history to uh be
contrarian and On's ideas and I have to
say I I was under no Illusions when I
was a grad
student being super excited about these
big biggest questions that anyone else
was going to Care in any way whatsoever
I I used to joke with my friends that if
if all I worked on was this you know my
next job was going to be in McDonald's
so I just accepted that and said that's
I'm not doing this for any kind of
public recognition I'm doing it because
I love it that's the best reason to do
science so I I I would make I didn't
even tell my thesis adviser about the
first these four papers I wrote as a
grad student I only showed them to him
after he had signed my dissertation I
just kept doing enough mainstream stuff
on the side that I could you know get
another job afterwards and it's actually
been been quite surprising to me that
many years later some of those old
things that I thought no one is ever
going to care about now some people are
actually building on them and and doing
things with them but I think the most
important thing is to do science for the
right reasons the right reason to do
science is this is the greatest
detective story ever you know we get to
be part of this amazing mystery solving
about our universe and its nature and
its origin and and Destiny and how cool
is that to get to be part of this
scavenger hunt you know in connect with
these great minds throughout history
that if that's our
motivation then
um we will never be
disappointed it's just going to be a
bonus if anyone else ever cares or
tweets it yes absolutely spoken like an
intellectual heroin addict I'm exactly
the same way Max uh my my feeling is is
that the problem of this detective story
as you say I haven't heard somebody call
it that that's great um is that it
competes pretty well with money uh and
sex and drugs and anything else you can
come up with it's hard to find anything
that you know if you offered somebody a
billion dollars or a Peak at the actual
understanding of the universe there's no
question that I wouldn't be taking a
billion dollars um
there is nothing like it and people
often say science is fun I don't really
think that's true most of the time it's
just really difficult and it's often
boring but it is the most deeply
fulfilling and at times Peak exciting
thing you can do with a human brain it's
astounding to me that something that we
use to find food and water can actually
understand partial differential
equations it's very very confusing that
that no it's it's a genuine mystery um
with respect to the uh the general
question remind me Brian of its
formulation what uh creativity of an
Einstein oh yeah no I remember can I
just chime in while you're clarifying
the question there Al say one more per
just personal thing I want to share that
I think is so rewarding is precisely
because I think about the grandest
questions simply
because I love
the the being part of this m mystery
solving it it also means that whenever I
run into other people like you Eric or a
lot of other physicists who who
obviously do it just because of that
reason then
um I feel a really touching kind of
Brotherhood Sisterhood with these people
right even more broadly just going to
physics like every single one of of my
colleagues in the MIT physics department
could easily multiply their salary by
piie if they went and did some something
on Wall Street or whatever right and
they don't right and that makes me feel
also a really cool kinship you know here
are all these people who have chosen to
make much less money to follow some
these things that they're passionate
about and and uh
we're this just makes me feel so uh
excited and honored to get to be part of
a community of people who are doing
things for this reason so I remember
your formulation think I think what
Brian what Max just said is incredibly
important imagine that if Eddie Van
Halen could have been a hedge fund
manager and multiplied his assets you
know would it have been worth it and we
wouldn't have Eddie Van Halen So it's
really important that things are able to
compete with money and um that that's
very tough when when inequality is so
high but it's really also important that
we boost the amount of funding to
scientists I just want to be very clear
about that the thing that you were
saying before um Brian about social
media there's an interesting feature
there's two kinds of really negative
behavior that affect a lot of us when
we're working on heterodox ideas there's
trolling uh negativity where people are
just taking a piece out of you and the
cookie cutter sharks are are tearing
Into Your Hide and extracting their
little core of fat and swimming off
happy that they've uh you know they've
trolled you they've dunked they've drank
they've dragged blah blah blah then you
have the same phenomena in a weird way
coming from your academicians and the
academicians I think the biggest
intellectual offense that I ever
experienced uh in physics again I'm not
a physicist but um was hearing string
theorists say well String Theory isn't
threatened because if you do anything
outside it will just tell you that it's
string theory and so we'll absorb you
and I thought wow cool uh what a
wonderful advertisement that your theory
can't be wrong because if we come up
with anything you've you've kept the
naming rights to say that what we do is
string theory
um I think that that negativity from our
colleagues and the negativity from the
trolls has a very important effect what
if really great theories were found by
people who were not highly disagreeable
now i' I've disagreed with the Susan
wiii even though I'm on YouTube with
Gavin with Gavin Nome I've said that
Sabine Hassen Felder is lying that she
doesn't have time for these theories I'm
obviously highly disagreeable doesn't
mean I'm I'm not personable but I've
been cultivating
this very trait because it's necessary
to do science when everybody is wrong so
in the great financial crisis I was part
of a very small number of people who
were saying this whole thing is going to
blow up Nim TB was another one and he
was disagreeable enough that when I quit
this game of going on conferences and
saying hey mortgage back Securities are
posing a real threat Nim said you're
going to regret crapping out in 2005 you
need to stay the course and I said
everyone's laughing at us
um I don't know whether you're not
paying attention you're not hearing he
says no no you're not getting it you you
you're you're bailing out of the trade
before the trade is actually mature and
I learned a lot from Nim theim is
incredibly disagreeable on the other
hand uh you need people who are like
Richard fireman and one of the things I
I might do on the portal this year is to
read his letter of resignation from the
National Academy of Sciences where he
didn't want to say why he was but he
just didn't want to be hooked up to his
peers and you know Max when you were
talking about the fact that your peers
are other physicists I'm very concerned
that we have too much group think in
physic in physics and we need to be
flipping the bird collegially and
constructively to our colleagues as well
as to the trolls and I do see that
there's a lot of commonality between
academicians who huddle around
respectability peer review the idea of
their accolades whatever Awards and
prizes they've been given whatever their
title is and and that too much we the
academicians in an era in which we have
not been advancing some of our Fields
quite as quickly as we used to have
become prisoners to the little bit of
respectability that we have left and we
need to reclaim the right to be highly
disagreeable without constantly saying
that everything comes from consensus the
most depressing part of this is the idea
that the so-called great man theory of
science is under attack by people who
claim a priori that it is always
communal when anything happens which is
preposterous particularly when you think
about how singular somebody like a dck
was or an Einstein was and or a Fineman
or a poy or a Weinberg and all of these
people are so individualistic to all of
us who've read their work that we have
to recognize that we are under some
generalized social attack for what it is
that we have proven Beyond any doubt we
do which is to use single individuals
disagreeing with their entire community
and getting the entire Community to come
along after the fact very good so let us
take a quick break and uh have a musical
interlude while I queue up some
questions because we have question you
know Max has a relativity song oh he
does okay well I know he's uh he was one
of the original members of ABA Getting
Back Together uh this is by my friend uh
Miguel Tully who's uh runs the yeti
tears website and other things so I'm
going to just look for some fun
questions and we'll get that queued up
so I'll put up another in the me oh yeah
there's a Yeti that's right I have a
Yeti tumbler somewhere around here Phil
a vodka getting ready for this rocking
New Year's Eve you're joining Max
tegmark Dr Eric Weinstein Professor Max
tegmark and yours truly Brian keing and
a special edition of the into the
impossible podcast all right we have a
question about entropy one of Max's
favorite topics this is by jmy Payne why
is the entropy at the beginning of time
low but the entropy in a black hole is
so
high a wonderful question why is entropy
at the beginning of time so low and
entropy in the black hole so high uh
first of all I said we have to be humble
and so I'll be the first to say we
actually don't know that the entropy was
low at the beginning of time we don't
even know if there was a beginning of
time that that's how how humble we have
to be here and what we do know
what what I I do feel we've learned
which is quite uh remarkable is that you
know first of all entropy for those of
you who
aren't who need a bit of refresher is
the physicist measure of how messy
things are so my room T from here where
I do this tends to get higher and higher
entropy Messier and Messier why is it
that you see things getting Messier why
is it that you've seen eggs fall on the
floor and break and not see them fly up
and Unbreak people argue about that for
very long time until sh the shocking
Insight came that the reason that that
the entropy is lower is higher now than
it was yet that it was lower this
morning than before I dropped the egg
than now is because it was even lower
yesterday and the reason for that was it
was even lower the day before that and
the reason for that was it was very low
13.8 billion years ago at the at the
time when those uh images baby pictures
of our universe were given off sitting
right behind you on the sofa there Brian
the causing mic your background and so
on so somehow our flow of time towards
greater messiness has something to do
with our origin of our universe that I
feel we have learned so that's progress
but now the question of why was that is
something where many of my colleagues
disagree violently with each other I
have
um written the paper there which I think
it's fair to say
uh has very little
support say what it concluded anyway
which is that if you take seriously the
idea of inflation and also the theory
that the wave function does not collapse
according to Everett you can do some
math and and get an explanation for for
why that happened but I think it's a
it's a wonderful mystery um and
um I'm open to all ideas for what what
the deal is with this and and black
holes came up here of
course which is something else we know
where ultimately where there are great
TR truth I think yet to be discovered so
we have a question from a a person with
a very lovely name I should have used it
for one of my children uh the name is
just given as R uh but R asks uh Eric uh
what advice would you give to a young
person pursuing a PhD in mathematics as
you pursue uh pursued back in the uh
1980s I
believe um take an
advisor what do you you mean I didn't
have an advisor and I did not understand
that and you don't need an adviser to do
mathematics you don't need an advisor
to come up with new ideas you need an
advisor to negotiate the
system
and uh in effect the way in which we
regulate population in mathematics is
that just like many Aven species uh we
don't feed certain chicks and if you
don't get fed as a chick it doesn't
matter how good your ideas are so in
large measure your
advisor is uh
somebody I didn't want an advisor but I
had to I had to try taking one then it
didn't work out and I just decided to do
it without and then it was forced upon
me you'll find that I can't fix my
Wikipedia entry because the system
insists that Raul bot was my adviser
lovely wonderful human being but he just
didn't happen to be my adviser the thing
then that I would say is once you had to
take an advisor you need to have a
really frightening conversation with
that person where you come in and you
say I know what my odds are and if you
are not willing to swing for the effing
fences I am going to die you've assessed
me I want you to tell me where I stack
in my chance of viability I don't care
about anything else I want to know
whether you think I am viable and if so
at what level and if that person is not
willing to say uh think you're one of
the top people and I will fight tooth
and nail to make sure you survive
provided you do what I think you're
capable of get out and you will not have
that conversation because you're going
to be a [__] about it and be by virtue
of not having that conversation you are
going to find out later that when that
person withholds the High Praise
necessary to secure a job for you and to
secure opportunities for you you will
then wither and die and um if you'll
just look at the survival rates if you
can't get to one of the top four or five
departments it's almost not worth going
that doesn't mean nothing good happens
below that but what you're dependent on
is a system of selective pressures in
which your parents have to kill and feed
you for a period of time before you can
hunt and kill for yourself and that s
situation is one in which you are going
to be squeamish and your adviser is
going to intimidate you away from asking
the questions but quite frankly having
done research in this area for the
American Society for cell biology
advisers usually form an impression
almost immediately whether you are
viable or not then your department will
extract labor out of you for a period of
time your adviser may get you to work on
sub routines for their career and then
your carcass will be discarded and if
you do not understand that this is what
has happened in the academic Hunger
Games uh you will not be able to defend
yourself the fact that nobody's talking
about it uh you watch nobody in the
University system will tell me that I'm
wrong they'll just tell me to shut up
now Max when you when you are approached
by a young beaver uh MIT um what what do
you look for in a promising young PhD
candidate or you've done a lot of work
with undergraduates but I recall you
being a very uh lovely mentor to me as a
graduate student when I was at Brown and
you were at Penn uh but even before that
when you were a postto I recall are good
advisers born or are they
made oh that I actually don't know but I
I will uh do my best to answer the rest
of your
question and and maybe first before I
even do that I'd like to just add a
little bit to to what Eric said there
because you painted a very very uh scary
sounding image of of Academia you
mentioned death many times and being
devoured and and and and like this and
for those out there listening who are
considering going into a job of Academia
I I I
actually feel a lot more optimistic
about and I would like to give a more
optimistic end of year message for those
of you and say go for it and and don't
be scared off by all this talk about
death there first of all you have to
remember that if you go into
Academia and for some and you have this
Vision that you're going to stay in
Academia for the rest of your life
and it doesn't end up that way what will
happen is not that you're going to
be starving to death somewhere in some
corner but that you will instead end up
in in doing something else where you're
going to make a lot more money than than
you would have in Academia and most
people I know who have left Academia are
seemed quite happy
right the so there's really not much to
be afraid of the second thing I would
say is yes it's I agree with you it's
very important to have an adviser who
can can support you I agree with you
there Eric um I I also think um if you
want to if you like Eric and me and
Brian and you're fascinated about big
questions that may be very unfashionable
at the time and have ideas that are
unfashionable uh I say pursue them
anyway but have a but do it as a
scientist where where you have a really
scientifically valid game plan also for
how your career is going to work
nonetheless right where you spend some
of your time doing what your heart is
burning for and then some of the time
just making sure that your career is
going to be fine anyway so you know you
Eric have solved it by making money in
other ways so that you can continue
doing s the great science that you do
right I similarly developed the strategy
very early where I I that I confessed
earlier where I would just write enough
mainstream papers that I could stay in
Academia and then on nights and weekends
and so on I would um do the things I
would I was really passionate about in
other words as long as you have a sort
of scientifically or Sound business plan
for how your career is going to go right
then uh don't be afraid of of following
your heart isn't it also a challenge
that we have you know I'm uh as as some
of my listeners know I'm a pilot and I
am actually a commercial pilot not for
you know wanting to deliver passengers
or mail or tow banners over the San
Diego Seashore I do it because uh when
I'm learning I am becoming a better
teacher and if you stop learning in
aviation you die and so one of the
things I started to do a few years ago
is get my uh flight instructor's uh
rating and to do that you need to be a
commercial pilot first so I got my
commercial pilot I got my and then I
started looking through well what does
it take to become a flight instructor it
turns out the Federal Aviation
Administration has one and only one to
my knowledge uh branch of government
that has in its handbook for
practitioners of this Federal agency it
has the words
love you imagine like the IRS like to be
a good IRS uh auditor you have to have
love no you have to have the opposite of
Love In some cases uh no no no offense
out there I mean Eric made fun of
YouTube that's more powerful than the
IRS so but uh but it has maso's
hierarchy of needs encoded in the
handbook of testing for future flight
instructors like me hopefully and I
wonder I never got sat down uh Max I
don't know if you did by my Dean or my
stagi old Dean or and they never said
well here's how you teach you need to
make sure that your students feel a
sense of Love David spurgle is famous
for saying that his best piece of advice
is that a student needs to feel love not
obviously it's platonic but um but but
the student needs to feel a sense of
love but when did you ever get taught
how to be a good teacher and maybe Eric
you're suffering because your a True
Advisor maybe didn't love you enough and
that's saying maybe you need more a
little more True Advisor I know that
that's what I'm saying you're a
self-made man Eric and you're in love
with your creator sorry I
I'm passionate about something here that
I I need I just need to to to say it in
a different way I love the fact that
Brian and Max and I are trying to take
our passion for this subject but you're
T if you're watching this live stream or
a recording of it you're looking at
three of the most anomalous people in
this game having a conversation as if
hey you can do this too my situation is
so exotic that I can't recommend it Max
you know is admitting that he's
effectively chosen the superhero route
you know mild Mander Clark Kent by day
Superman by night or you know Bruce
Wayne or who knows what look here's what
you need to do go to the math genealogy
project okay look for everybody who was
a uh for the survival rates of advisors
before
1972 and the survival rates of their
students after 1972 we had an act actual
Singularity happened in our markets in
around between 1971 and
73 and if you look at somebody like
Norman steenrod who stopped advising
when he died I guess in the early 70s
almost all of his students survive and
if you look at anybody like the top
advisers today they can't match that
previous thing so max is quite correct
you can bounce into a certain number of
technical Fields if you do it at a high
enough level many people don't make it
to Google they don't make it to Great
sixf fig jobs that you know give them
fulfillment many do depends where you're
going I'm trying to give you the tough
love Max is trying to give you the
optimism and I think it's great having
both go look at the data and ask every
Department that you're applying to can
you please show me your outcome
statistics and show me how well you've
done because we're all lying about the
fact that since 1971 through 73
academics has been in a depression
period the end all right Max how do you
react to that I didn't claim the I I
wasn't lying I didn't I didn't have said
nothing to dispute that fact that
there's that there's been a very sad
development and and the support from
society in terms of funding for Academia
and that that's just the way it is I and
I think I wish it could change but even
in the sit in the poor situation we are
now you know where the amount of money
spent on all physics funding in the
United States in a year right is less
than a couple days of military budget uh
even in that state I think going into
science is really good move if you're
excited about it and I would encourage
listeners to do it and and here is here
is my data that you asked for I you know
really really get attached to my past
students and I try to keep in touch with
them over the years and and to the very
best of my knowledge every single one so
half a dozen of them are or so are
professors now uh a bunch more probably
will be a number of them have left and
gone into other fields but every single
one of them to the best of my knowledge
is quite happy with the fact that they
did science first and and and and let me
just finish here so so um I I think that
uh there there's no real indication that
it's a recipe for an unhappy life to go
into science and contrarywise
uh as as long as you have an exciting
time while you're doing the science and
then maybe later you do something else
you know what's so bad about that you
know you're we're all going to die
anyway for real at some point that's not
an excuse to not make the most of Life
while we're still alive right and um let
me just say say something very quickly
which Max can't say Max is also
exceedingly conscientious and concerned
about this by founding fqxi and giving
even small grants to people a lot of
what Max has been doing has been taking
care of the heterodox community in all
of physics so you're looking at in some
sense the most anomalous person in our
space well I act as the antimatter to
him then I'm I'm the worst adviser
possible as my students will
test you're in a different area where
we're talking really really theory for
the most part Max and Anthony aguire the
the co-founder I don't know how you guys
um these guys are serious about trying
to keep the field afloat and Max is not
is coupling his optimism with the fact
that he's going above and beyond what
almost anyone else is doing and I think
it's fantastic that's why I love hanging
out on this live stream but I just don't
want to give the indication that Max is
somehow your typical Prof there's
obviously survivorship bias that's
coming in here but I I have to say as I
said earlier one of the names that Max
will recognize is my friend Chris Odell
who is the graduate student who came
after me at Peter timy who is my adviser
and Peter timy is coming on the into the
impossible podcast so those of you out
there get to hear from my PhD adviser
what a schmendrick uh I was back 30
years ago a brave guy you are I just
love him and he's going to talk about
his adviser David Wilkinson uh who Max
also knew but Max was like this when he
was a postu so I think Max is predn
naturally gifted in this way I do think
that as we learn about quantum mechanics
Max or as we learn about uh you know
ological field Theory or or whatever uh
Eric does we need to also spend time
learning about how to teach how to
manage how to lead I've had a lot of
Nobel prize winning experimentalists on
my show lately and the question I keep
asking them is how did like Barry barish
and Ray Weiss who led the coolled the
ligo experiment that won the Nobel Prize
in 2017 uh they foolishly left their
Nobel Prize with me when they did the
show I picked the pockets clean after
they got off of my couch over there but
the point is we have to study these soft
skills and I think one of my colleagues
here Darren leomy does a great job he
teaches a whole YouTube and course about
the soft skills outside of the
laboratory so I just want to say that
before we move on to the question of
academic funding and one of the ways I
am solving this problem of academic
funding is I'm accepting super chats I
am taking Super Chat no uh this is not
how I'm going to do it actually though I
do want to donate um the proceeds from
today to both of your guys favorite
Charities you guys will tell me
afterwards uh and it can't be you know
to to the Brian keing fund I I won't do
that but I'll donate all the money I'm
getting from the super chats you're
willing if it's the Revolutionary Afghan
women's Association you are a brave I
get their newsletter what are you
talking about am I willing all right I
subscribe buddy uh and Max will will
obviously do it to any of the projects
you're interested in so please keep
those super chats coming we have one
from Sweden we have a Swedish Chrono Max
tell me if this is a lot of money we
have 100 Swedish croner coming from waim
Peters Pon uh who asked can I ask
Max and uh and Eric if they follow John
Williamson Thad Rogers joh Mackin theory
of SpaceTime as a fluid uh first of all
Max am I going to be able to put my kids
through college with this 100 Swedish
croner and do you think about SpaceTime
as a fluid with those 10 bucks thank you
have to say
tax make sure to put it to send it to a
charity that puts it to good
use the um I clearly do need to follow
this Theory since I'm I'm the first to
admit that I don't know about as much
about it as I should Eric do you want to
anything about it ER I got nothing all
right fine we'll move on next Super Chat
we have
2,000 oh my God 2,000 Russian rubles
which I think is about uh what
Eric I thought you said something are
you are you are you are you suggesting
Russian collusion this is Russian
collusion for Eric Weinstein uhoh Eric
do you think that the perceived loss of
information that happened s when a
Quantum system collapses is because of
equal probability events present in the
set of causal chains of that Quantum
system I.E is there no other
distinguishing Factor we can identify I
think he's asking Alexander
apost I can't pronounce his last name
Alexander Sasha uh asking do you what do
you think of the perceived loss of
information when a wave function
collapses okay uh I don't think much
about it uh I think that um this has to
do with the fact that we formulated
quantum theory is going to be with us
forever but I don't believe it's going
to look like it currently does with this
sort of deterministic propagation
followed by violent uh introductions of
probability when you ask bad questions
that is where the state is not an igen
State uh of the observable representing
your question and I think that a lot of
what we have is we have
a theory that is good enough to work and
get results but is philosophically
unsatisfying and the way in which we
used to weed people out in physics is
you had to profess that you actually
accepted that this is exactly the way
the world Works more or less and my
feeling is this is the way the world
Works relative to our current framework
which is clearly telling us don't overdo
the analysis until we get to the right
framework I think this is really what
Einstein was saying he wasn't saying
that he hated quantum theory he said
that he hated the idea that we were
going to rush to say hey the universe is
queerer than we can suppose hdan was
right and wow this just proves that some
of us can accept it and some of you guys
are stuck in your classical world I
think that the problem is we've got way
too much
gwiz in our physics and it gwiz is fun
it just doesn't actually move the needle
so I'm always up for trying to remove G
whz to get to the fun of looking for a
better framework and I hope that gu will
start to push in that direction can I
add something
this I think that's a that's the
question about the wave function collaps
there look I think the wave function
just does not collapse this was the
first way I got in trouble in physics
actually with the Swedish Professor Eric
you'll be proud of me for this um we
swedes never pass up an opportunity to
make fun of Denmark and talk smack about
them so I good for you won't miss that
chance now either Neil bore and the
Copenhagen
interpretation I respond with Hamlet
something is rotten in the state of
Denmark my God talk about Stockholm
syndrome the look the wave function does
not collapse let's face it there there's
absolutely no experimental evidence for
it it appears to collapse yes but what
you ever had showed so beautifully
already back in the60s is that 50s and
60s that is that even if it does not
collapse if you just drop that entirely
and and just say go with a shirting your
equation all the way it's going to
appear like it collapses and it's going
to appear like it collapses Accord to
all the usual Copenhagen interpretation
rules and I would go as far as saying
that this it doesn't even have anything
par fundamental to do with quantum
mechanics it just if you have any sort
of physics which lets you make copies of
an observer classically or Quantum
mechanically you will experience
apparent randomness I like to imagine
that uh and suppose you Brian do you
want to clone yourself for the new year
so you can get twice as much done uh
yeah then I could you know we'll take
you into the San Diego San Diego Medical
Center and put one we'll sedate you and
and I'm telling you now you're going to
wake up it's going to be January 1st
2020 will be over at one copy of you
wakes up in room one the other copy
wakes up in room two in the hospital
okay what do you predict is going to be
the first thing you experien when you
walk outside your your hospital room and
look at the room number my wife's going
to yell at two guys that look like me at
the same time but what are you going to
see are you going to see a room sign
that says you in room one or or you see
a two you cannot predict this because
you know there will be two experiences
one one Brian experienced is one one two
so the best thing you can say is I'm
going to go and I'm going to look and
I'm going to say oh this seems random
I'm going to either see a one or two
with equal probability this is what I
think fundamentally is happening in
quantum physics too um the quantum
reality is just bigger than the one we
thought we lived in before quantum
mechanics and it has this ability that
it can start with something which is in
one way and make effectively it being in
two ways and and then when we make a
measurement sometimes we find out which
copy we we were so I wouldn't worry
about the wave function collaps I think
that's a tremendous amount of technical
debt to go to many worlds to take on to
get rid of the collapse of the I mean in
other words it it it does strike me that
what we've entered an era in which we
can solve many of these problems if you
don't mind that we're positing something
even wild I mean wildly more outrageous
which way doesn't mean it's false just
means depends on depends on what what
you measure outrageousness in right if
if what you mean is that something is
more extravagant if it if it if it
involves somehow having more particles
or reality being bigger yeah then sure
uh but I think you and I Eric both feel
that maybe the kind of Simplicity that
we should value with aam's Razer is
rather that the the math is simple the
equations are simple that's a very
interesting point and I do think that
what I'm not saying that Max techmark
cannot get out of Max Tech Mark's
technical debt I'm saying that it would
take a a very good day being Max TEEG
Mark to get out of Max TEEG Mark's
technical debt in in so doing that by
the way your much more partial to the
Schrodinger equation than I ever
imagined I even got my wife to agree to
have it hanging on the
wall that's his love that was his first
tweet to his wife I love you dear here
you go uh so we're getting other
questions that uh I want to come to but
I do think Eric and I have talked about
this um kind of the whizbang approach to
physics that I believe is a little
detrimental and and your mutual friend
Lex Friedman up there has had on other
characters in addition to the two of you
guys one by the name of miio Kaku who
will talk waxing rapaic about the mind
of God and how everything is encrypted
and encoded and if we can get to the
Multiverse and that really would be the
singular I find that I like Mio I he's
very good as an Entertainer but I think
the selling of physics is going to come
back to Haas and and kind of the just
touting this stuff uh and I'm guilty of
it at times too but you know I won't end
you utter the mind of God what do you
think about this the danger that we as
people that are publicly facing have of
potentially compromising the true
appreciation of the most magnificent
things in the universe which take a lot
of background you can't dumb it down and
you shouldn't I will never do that with
my audience go ahead Eric
first it's a really interesting and
tough question uh I I kind of hate it to
be blunt because I feel like a lot of I
mean let's let's be frank about this it
used to be the case that we reserved the
right to talk to the public in this
fashion for the very top people and they
sort of did it sparingly and we made
yeah we made certain um you know it's
one thing uh if you've got gof talking
to the public you know great figures in
your field but somehow we've got these
science entrepreneurs and you know I I
would even I don't think that's
primarily what I am but you could make
an argument that I've become partially a
science
entrepreneur and I try to go away from
this language now if you ask me
privately what animates me it's very
tough when you're talking about the the
basis of reality itself to say come on
don't make too much out of it it's like
what the hell I me come on the only
reason to do this stuff is that you're
talking about existence and can you
please speak more modestly and less per
with less purple language about um
existence itself I don't know it's a
challenge this is what I you know I I go
to synagogue where I don't believe but I
feel and I'm filled with the spirit of
uh of the
service that's one thing okay you're all
singing and praying together it's
another thing when you're alone at your
whiteboard and you feel like holy [__] I
I am I in an Indiana Jones movie I'm so
close to the base to to to the hardware
the metal it's like uh it's
uncomfortably close to religion and I
think
that what I find is is that weirdly we
talk about the mind of God for two
reasons when we're getting really far
away from success in physics and we need
some side hustle in order to keep people
interested by the way this is the same
language that we uh in math and physics
use to hit on our our potential mates
um you know we we we talk about the mind
of God when we go to a party if we have
to compete with a guy with actual money
who can play the guitar um so we pick
that up as a bad habit but when you're
also when you're succeeding at science
that's the other time that you start to
to to get into this and so weirdly if I
hear somebody talk about the mind of God
I I tend to think that they're either
getting really far away from success or
that they've uh gotten very close and
they've reminded themselves
holy crap you know when I'm doing my
stuff I'm actually talking about
something that is so profound I can't
even believe I'm allowed to address it
or have enough information to feel that
after standing on the shoulders of so
many nested giants like a giant metka
you know um we've got it's Giants all
the way down and you're on these
shoulders maybe I'm going to be the one
to you know each one of us to to turn in
the Baton at the end of the really race
who am I going to be turning this baton
into what if I actually what if you have
a theory of everything we don't actually
spend time with this it's a terrifying
idea that just as the last land mass on
Earth was at some point mapped you just
lost Don Wells remember the Uncharted
desert Isle of Gilligan's Island with
satellite imagery we don't believe in it
I don't know that we would have said
Uncharted desert aisle in the modern
don't have that and MaryAnn let's um
yeah that's what I'm saying Don Wells oh
Don Wells I thought yeah yeah Don Wells
right right and so so my belief about
this is that uh you shouldn't fault
somebody for talking about the mind of
God you should just ask yourself is this
because their research isn't working or
it's really working and in general it's
almost always the case these days that
it's because our research isn't working
so max I have a question about theories
of everything oh go ahead can I of
course in on this one also about whether
we overs simp whether we oversimplify
too much and whatnot you know I really
love Einstein's quot that we should uh
tell things as simple as possible and no
simpler this is what I always aspire to
whether I'm teaching a course or giving
a research colloquium or talking to the
person next to me on the airplane and U
I actually feel I was not
oversimplifying when I said talked about
the collapse of the wave function there
the argument I gave for you in the
hospital that was the full argument it
wasn't some sort of Dum down version if
you think it through again on your own
free time I think you will conclude that
yeah you will experience apparent
Randomness that's my clone calling you
yeah and and then I if people come back
and ask me follow-up questions I'm
willing to go as far down the rabbit
hole as they want so you know here for
example is the shorting re equation
again right that and what it's actually
saying is that the state of the world
that's this Greek letter s there this
bracket around it right it's saying that
the rate of change of
it is given depends on the current state
of the world and you do this operation
on it and and for the math nerds this is
a linear operation which means that if
the actual state of the world is this
thing plus that thing the
rate
then the same thing the rate of change
will be the the that operation on the on
the sum of the two things of the and and
is what that just means is as Everett
has pointed out and many others have
known for a very long time is that in
some circumstances two different
solutions to this can do their parallel
thing we can talk at Great length about
about the discoveries later about
decoherence and and why it is that
sometimes these different parallel
branches are unaware of each other and
but my point is know if you give a
science nerd colloquium to to at a
physics department I I think ideally you
should also start in the same way you
start start discussing this with your
grandma just at the very high level you
know here are the cool ideas and then
you can go as deep as as the audience or
The Listener wants from there but Max
it's not clear to
me even listening to this I I really
liked what you said in in the hospital
by it's sort of a Sydney Coleman thing
where you try to take the Majesty of
quantum mechanics and you divorce it
from some of the accidents which people
confus uh confuse it with and so by
coming up with a classical version I
really like that what I don't know is
whether or not it's really an
isomorphism to the same phenomena
because what what you did is if if I if
I look at Consciousness I think Brian
goes to sleep in the example so
Consciousness is paused and then we have
an action where you're trying to treat
Consciousness like it's
mitosis and we clone the thing or we
call spawn inside of a computer and then
there's the Awakening so the quessing is
an important part of your story could
you have told the same story without
quessing the system called Brian
keing if it
happened so fast much much faster than
the time scale of a tenth of a second or
100th of a second on which Brian reacts
I think uh the argument is the same
although I think we don't have surgeons
that quick and S even in San Diego
that's the a you understand what I'm
trying to say it's not clear to me that
it's an isomorphism indeed and and we
don't know for sure that this Shing
equation is actually that accurate a
description of nature either that's why
it's so exciting to see what's going to
happen with the quantum computer efforts
right now right will they ultimately
fail because physics isn't fully
described by the shinger equation or
will they actually succeed you know this
is where ultimately our experimental
friends will will uh so give us crucial
insights as to what even the shinger
equation like you know this is the non-
relativist we know that the schroer
equation is
wrong well it's it's right it's not
complete we can also take Quantum field
Theory and T no I understand what you're
saying what I'm trying to get at is that
we have a situation in which when we
talk to the public I'm very sympathetic
with what you're trying to do or even
our colleagues the problem is is that
great analogies you know I do I do a
superposition analogy classically with
change in your pockets where some of
it's in Swiss frank some of it's in
pounds but the landing card says is your
change in either Swiss Franks or is it
in uh British pounds and then the idea
is that there's no both and so because
the the multiple choice answers don't
list
superposition classical mechanics uh
remains mute and quantum mechanics
weirdly says I'm going to convert all
your money into one or the other because
the landing card says it by some m
process I'm very fond of these things
the problem is is that even when you say
that you're removing these things an
astute listener can can often spot wait
a second that's not actually an analogy
because if I tracked it exactly there
was a slight of hand sometimes the
slight of hand matters I don't think in
what you were doing with the Schrodinger
equation being non-relativistic that you
were using any slight of hand I do think
in the Consciousness question by not by
not addressing the quessing of the
system it's not clear that that's
actually kind of a fair fair point yeah
so before we just to bring closure to
this uh you I'll be the first to admit
that we ultimately don't know what's
going on exactly with with quantum
mechanics my personal guess I I'm happy
to tell you because I like betting is
that uh even quantum mechanics is
probably an emergent Theory there maybe
an approximation of of of of something
deeper maybe we can get it out of gu
somehow uh but um I also would guess o
would guess frankly and here I am I
guessing the opposite of your of Roger
Penrose who you had on here
earlier that um gravity doesn't
really have much to do with this I think
you can look at be in a in a spaceship
far away from any really any important
gravitating objects and do your little
Quantum experiments with a Stern gerlock
apparatus and you would get all the
same fascinating things
happening so I think blame it I I think
um ignoring gravity altogether ignoring
relativistic effects altogether you can
you still have this thing that people
love fighting about and arguing about
what does a way function collapse or not
and that's why I'm so interested in
um and this kind of discussion we had
where get at those very questions
without worrying about that stuff so
let's take a
break give you guys a a DJI air horn for
you guys uh that was awesome my sound
effects are coming into play uh so we
we're still sort of uh diverging from
one question I was very curious to get
both of your opinions about and that's
this issue of funding in physics and I'm
an experimentalist you guys are
theorists uh mostly Eric says he's not a
physicist please Eric you're an honorary
physicist now we will ma that's up to
you guys it's not not an honary
physicist you're a real phys real he's
doing physics things I'm very honored
I'd love to be thank you guys it's not
for me to say okay fine anyway you come
down here you're in my lab you're a
physicist anyway we've talked about this
Eric but I want to get Max's take on it
I feel theory is in a sense um less
costly in other words it's easier to
make theories just like it's easier it's
not easier intellectually but it's there
are more programs in the world than
there are different types of computers
there's more programming languages than
than uh phone uh models for example so I
make the analogy that theory is kind of
like software and experiments like I do
are kind of like hardware and and
therefore it's very precious but I get a
lot of emails I'm sure both of you guys
do uh you know I've got this theory of
the early Universe uh I need to you know
or of grand unification can you help me
prove it and I'll share you know my
Nobel Prize proceeds with you I actually
asked that of Adam Ree and he said yeah
how do you think I won the Nobel Prize
in physics uh uh but but in reality we
there's there's so many there's a
proliferation of it experiments are
expensive I am myself really at the whim
of Jim Simons whose generosity has uh
granted me and my 300 colleagues on the
Simons Observatory the privilege of
building an experiment which could
potentially reveal evidence more
evidence or some evidence uh in some
cases for things like the Multiverse or
inflation I want to ask you guys what do
we need in physics uh that the tech
industry does so well in software do we
need I had this idea of a y combinator
you know for physics how do we get more
either more experiments to look at
theories or use exis data from
experiments as Max has done to
investigate the consequences of theory
and and how do we raise money for it uh
for physics as a whole it's the our
Crown Jewel of civilization many people
feel so max I'll start with you uh how
would you if you were you know kind of
uh responsible for for raising funds it
it seems extremely difficult how do we
do it to promote it for the net benefit
of
humanity there were really two separate
questions in there right how shall we do
the physics best given funding and how
should we get the funding so for the
first part how should we do it I think
uh I really want to avoid to try to give
some glib answer to it because it's a
strength not a weakness that so many
physicists around the world have
different ideas of how it should be done
we want to try look not just all under
the same lamp posts but search and many
different ways with many different
approaches
uh uh for the second question how you
fund it so you can have a healthy
diverse community of of people going
after this great uh mystery of how the
world works right there I think um yes
it's great that that there are
philanthropists like Simons and that
will listen enough to scientists to
actually you know fund them but I
actually think it's also a big mistake
as a species if we um
don't create institutions and
governments
which support science there have been a
number of very nerdy economic studies
that have showed very clearly that
investing in basic science is the
highest return on investment basically
ever and you're the expert who can push
back on on this Eric but inventing the
transistor you know just basic basic
physics research um has has benefited us
so much in in so many ways you know
inventing calculus you know it didn't
cost that much but it's been so so
valuable so I think as a society frankly
uh we have to think and this comes back
to the whole media question again you
know there are much more people who have
heard about the
Kardashians than who can
name three living scientists
even let alone 20 right we created a
culture where scientists are not not
only are they not particularly known
about or viewed as Role Models or Heroes
but they're even very actively attacked
by a a lot of folks with power for whom
what the scientific what scientists are
saying is inconvenient and um I really
think that if we can the one of the best
things we can do for science funding is
just create a less screwed up media
landscape where we actually
appreciate how much we benefit from
scientific research that governments
will actually support it again right
it's it it's pretty we spent two billion
dollar a day or more in this country
alone on military
right if you could get a puny puny
fraction of that into scientific
research we wouldn't even be having to
have this conversation about how we get
funding for science amica's had an
analogy to the military calling
theoretical physics the intellectual
equivalent of SEAL Team Six so Eric how
would you fund physics or how do you uh
how do you propose that we crack this
particular
nut there are four basic arguments um
the first one that I like the most um
will fall flat but it's Max's argument
which is um so I'm not not I'm not
ragging on Max I'm saying he's got the
best argument but it just doesn't work
it's the greatest mystery in the world
you don't want to know how it ends
you're not interested in how the plot
develops that has to do with the fact
that we have not brought people
along if you can't understand you know
the mystery of chirality if you don't
even know what chirality is and whether
or not we're going to solve it is not
going to be interesting to you it's like
a murder mystery where we don't even
tell people what this you know what the
crime is so in part that's on us we
should be making the greatest mystery uh
accessible to the public but it doesn't
seem to work then there's the military
argument do you really want do you have
any idea how powerful your physics
Community is and how much it is
accomplished for you and you want you
can have these guys for at pittance on
permanent retainer to make sure that
when something goes bump in the night
you got the world's smartest people at
your fingertips on speed dial what is
your effing problem that you're that
you're causing them to talk about
funding I never want to hear the two of
you talk about funding again in your
lives it pains me that working
physicists are constantly in this
conversation let me keep going with the
arguments though the next one uh you
know is an argument about the fact that
physics has doomed you since the early
1950s 52 to 54 we are going we are in
the Valley of Death if we do not figure
out a way to become a space fairing
civilization you can kiss your
indefinite future on this planet goodbye
physicists without the wisdom of gods
became as powerful as gods in the
1950s and we do not have a long-term
plan for civilization we've had 75 years
of unexplainable quiet following World
War II because we dropped two physics
devices uh in Japan and scared the
living [__] out of every sentient being
who's paying attention and that is not
going to hold and so you were going to
be in deep deep trouble but the last
argument is probably the most useful one
and it's not one that I love which is
let's talk about your beautiful taxpayer
dollars they don't exist most of your
taxpayer dollar is a physics dollar and
let me explain it I'm going to start
talking about some things that come out
of physics whether it's electron shells
whether it's the transistor and
semiconductors as Max just uh talked
about in semiconductor instructions that
power your computers and the devices
that you're watching this on whether
it's uh the development of the
electromagnetic spectrum whether it's
the worldwide web that came out of
CERN um I'm going to keep going and
going and going and at the end I'm going
to say how much is left of your
beautiful beautiful taxpayer dollar that
uh that you're so worried that you don't
why should you spend it on
us this is one of the reasons why I'm
not accepting you guys calling me a
physicist I I don't necessarily even
like your community all the time but
this is the most important intellectual
community that has ever existed and it
is intellectually offensive in the
highest order to have it try to explain
what it has done for you the old joke
which Janet Jackson made famous is what
have you done for me lately that's the
that's the
punchline suck it up physics had signed
the world's worst licensing deal in
human history anytime you want to in you
want to revisit that and say what would
be a fair price for what we I think wait
wait wait wait just let me let me get to
the end of the effing ramp anytime you
want to readdress how much physics has
provided for you in that taxpayer dollar
and you want to sign a licensing
agreement in a real years that covers
the worldwide web the semiconductors
chemistry blah blah blah electromagnetic
spectrum be my guest and you will be
watching physicists flying around with
flying their kids around in multiple
private jets and you will be you will
you will be their private chefs be quiet
listen to what you've gotten from this
community it doesn't ask for much shut
up suck it up and make sure that these
people stop talking about funding which
is boring and it's also embarrassing but
if you want to if you want to let the US
uh at the mer be at the mercy of China
if you want it to live with nuclear
weapons where we're not trying to get
off this plan if you want any of those
things it's because you're not paying
attention please find somebody who is
and talk about this locally with them
until you understand the situation a
little bit better all right Max Max a
million I'm GNA put the million in there
now Max Go for you I just have to say
you know my favorite movie of all time
is of course the one about your life
Life of Brian Python and I we really
should try to reenact this epic skit
about what have the Romans ever done for
us by saying what is phys what has
physics ever done for us so embarrassing
internet but yes yes that's true but
besides physics besides the internet and
transistors what has physics ever done
for us on and on you should you guys
should we'll do that but I mean I'll get
back my wife doesn't you know much to
her CH grin can't go back and say well
you know when I married you you were you
know 20 pounds lighter and I can't well
your cooking is so good dear no I mean
you we didn't sign a deal there are no
deals so the question is how do we
go hold on hold on yes I I want to get
to immigration also Eric because we're
talking to an immigrant a dangerous
immigrant right now uh but but I want I
want to get to that in a second because
I I do think there there's a kernel of
Truth there but let me just say this
we're making the exact same mistakes it
wasn't just the endless Frontier cubits
were invented by physicists guess who's
using cubits well Quantum Computing is
using cubits what is it doing Max and I
are going to talk later this year about
uh about artificial intelligence in some
dep we're making the same mistakes now
it's not only because of the Endless
Frontier van ever Bush all these guys it
we are making it's built into who we are
we are not good because we don't get
training in it Eric we never get
training on the financial end of things
that you have a patural ability uh to do
perhaps or Jim Simons does I don't have
any training in economics fine you have
a preder natural gift then but uh most
of us don't so question is what do we
need I I made this this comment someone
in the chat room is suggesting
blockchain I thought about that too is
there any application a y combinator for
physics where we put people that want to
get the next CU bit before it's too late
we're never going to backmon forget it
we're never going to get a a a dollar
for each email that was sent that's not
going to happen but going forward do we
have to make the the same mistake that
we made 45 times in the uh 20th century
alone I think I really don't want to
have this conversation I I'll be honest
with you you I'm embarrassed that we we
try to come up with reasons that we have
to reason look hey public you know who
Einstein is you know who fan is you
can't stop talking about them uh I'm not
I'm not I'm not justifying how do we go
forward wait wait wait wait wait I
understand
that there are lots of things we can do
if we have funding to make the the field
exciting inviting to get the PE the
talent we have to compete for talent
with things that actually pay and to
have people constantly focused on their
Grant and all this stuff we have
devitalized ourselves I don't think we
need why combinate or any of these
things if we can save the system I think
Brian what your secret question really
is is assuming we can't save the system
how do we go to blockchain how do we go
to Y combinator how do we do this and
I'm not done because I'm concerned that
you guys need friends who are not
physicists to explain what theoretical
physics has done in a new way to people
who are newly nervous about this planet
by the way I forgot to throw in
molecular biology which was largely
founded by who physicist physicist
absolutely right it's so absurd that
when we make the argument it is as if we
are insecure about what we have done and
I refuse to be insecure in front of the
public period we need more people Max I
mean is it is it a lack of people that's
holding back physics Finance I'm just
talking about funding right now I mean
is is Elon Musk fundamentally limited by
the computing power that he has or the
number of bright Engineers that he
has look I
I many years ago I I promised myself to
never ever pity
myself and I I think I've kept it you
know I I think it's important to
remember physicists are not the only
group on this planet who
uh maybe don't quite get the resources
that they think they should have that
right there were more people who died of
starvation this year then who died of Co
and we don't even really read about it
in the newspapers because for some for
some reason this is how how media works
right um there were more people who died
of tuberculosis this year and last year
combined than have died of Co this year
we don't hear about them either very
much because of the way the media works
so somehow uh I think we the what's
happening in science that science isn't
has trouble with getting funding and
also that scientists have their opinions
not listen to very much is just a small
symptom of a more broadly screwed up
world and um maybe sometimes the just
like in physics sometimes the easy way
to solve a little problem is to go and
find unified theory that higher do it at
a higher level maybe the easiest way to
get science out of it screwed up
situation is to just make Society itself
a bit more a bit less screwed up I don't
know what you think Eric I think we
could what we could do is we could try
look let me say something about your
community that again you can't say the
reason that physics is so powerful is
that it does something that no other
community can easily do which is that it
it gets the hybrid Vigor of the dirt of
the if if I go to Brian's lab where he's
building telescopes it is as gritty as
you can possibly imagine to get clean
results you have to be welding things
and soldering all this kind of stuff on
the other hand when I look at what's
behind Max on his uh background um it is
the purest most beautiful stuff it's
like listening to Bach it's just it
effectively uh is this magical Purity
and by getting the you know it's like
you're
combining these two most extreme things
and there's something about this
intellectual thought process that if I
wanted to cure
tuberculosis believe me I would actually
go to physicist if I wanted to cure
problems in the economy I would go to
physicist it's what physics does in
training if it works and if we stop
going the path because I think physics
training is becoming less valuable all
the time unfortunately as we drift but
when physics works the
the combination of Purity and and and
dirt and also the fact that so many
problems are surprisingly simple once
you get past the incredible hurdle
needed to understand them this is why
the physics Community is always at the
scene of every great
uh you know for Humanity and so if we're
stealing you know things away from from
malaria or or famine or or any things to
make humans happier and better you're
always going to find physicists at the
scene of the crime because there's
something in the training that's
fungible which is why when I forgot
molecular biology can you imagine that
your community more or less founded
molecular biology and I can't even be
bothered to remember to remember it
while I'm listing all the things we've
done it's posterous and because um when
you guys say it it sounds like you
you're there with a begging Bowl I
prefer to have friends say it for you
you need the Elon musks who almost
became a physicist the Mark Zuckerberg's
the Yuri milers whoever to get together
and say hey we need to agitate for our
friends these if you guys do it it won't
work we need to do it from outside third
party praise so let me give you some
Applause right there Max do you want to
have a follow up on that before we
switch to another topic if you guys have
time I don't know how's your time going
guys I I love this but it's up to you
guys I'm good for for for a lot more of
Max's uh I just want to remind people to
go to Max's new project to check it out
it's called improve theen news.org go to
Eric Weinstein's Channel on YouTube look
up the portal subscribe to the portal uh
and if you're enjoying this live stream
just hit the uh Thumbs Up Button stretch
your thumbs don't get carpal tunnel
syndrome it kills 800 billion people a
year uh stretch your thumbs hit the
Subscribe button hit the like button if
you're enjoying this conversation cuz
I'm having such a good time with these
incredible brilliant uh friends of mine
that I'm privileged to spend the time
with because of things like the internet
that we love and hate and I want to turn
now back to Max you have a quick
followup on that and before we get to
some some tless and practical wisdom
from the two of you yeah so just to
share a final thought on this business
about scci physics and science more
broadly and and how to get people to how
to get both get people listening more to
it so that the world gets run in a more
reasonable way and also so that it don't
we don't have to do so much begging uh I
think um physicists we we we we have a
certain arrogance actually which which
has harmed us a lot uh is that we we
forget that we're in a bubble and
the that we forget that there's actually
a science of how you persuade people
there's actually a science of how to
communicate and other people have
studied that at Great length I would say
that the average person who works making
cigarette ads is much more scientific
about the way they get their message out
than the average physicist and and I
think it comes not from stupidity on
behalf of the physicist but from
arrogance and that somehow no we're not
going to stoop so low that we're going
to be scientific about how we
communicate right scientific about how
we Advocate we have to get off our high
horses you know if you get invaded
by Hitler's Army you shouldn't just say
well you know tanks are immoral we're
going to fight them with swords we have
to be scientific also about standing up
for ourselves and and our ideas and and
so forth and I part of that another
second mistake I think we make is
forgetting that we live in a bubble and
and spending much more time infighting
in within our community of physicists uh
or within having one science pitted
against another science for a few more
tax dollars you know losing sight of the
fact that there's a tiny trickle of
money that flows to all the Sciences
combined anyway compared to what goes
into generic fruits of of of Lobby
Corporate lobbying and and and random
waste you know so so get out of our
bubble again we if we look at the big
picture it's kind of pathetic really
that you have physicists biologists
chemists who together have built up most
of the wealth of the world and managed
to be so incredibly Naval gazing and
busy with infighting and oldfashioned
and how they communicate
that they have to come begging for money
and people don't don't listen to them
can we actually can I just tell yeah go
for a quick story from uh from the
malaria
uh uh Wars effectively there used to be
a problem where you had a tiny budget
for certain diseases that affected large
numbers of people who didn't happen to
live where the money was and um still
time right yeah and uh but there was a
change back I guess in the 90s maybe 80s
90s where I remember Jeffrey Sach taking
my wife P Milani onto a phone call and
she was trying figure out how to
allocate this tiny little budget and his
point to her was it's immoral for us to
be trying to do this what we need to do
is to push the budget out and to stop
accepting the constraint and that's part
of why I was a little bit resistant I
wasn't because Brian was making bad
points about why combinator it's that I
I can't I refuse to start thinking about
this problem in Earnest uh at this level
this is such a clear mismatch that the
first thing is to
cure our society wants to spend more
money on science and it wants to spend
less money on stupid stuff and by the
way the really big Pro the really stupid
thing that we did was around the SSC
cancellation the superc conducting super
collider where the arrogance of the
community did not play well in
Washington as times had changed and I
highly recommend going back to like 1992
93 in the Congressional hearings and
reading how pissed off Congress was that
when they found the National Science
Foundation lying and then they found the
physicist buying too much art for their
offices at the uh at the SSC and things
like that so it's very important that we
also do our part to say look hey we are
going to spend some money on Art
beautiful buildings and things that make
us happy we have conferences in
beautiful location suck it up it's a pit
and stop complaining on the other hand
know that we are serious as a heart
attack when it comes to using this money
for things that really matter sometimes
all of that kind of luxury promotes the
idea I went to a a Max conference in B
it's one of the most beautiful places
but that facilitated lots of people
feeling that we could take the risks to
do new things whereas if you're
constantly keeping people at a minimal
level of sustenance they you know
necessity is the mother of very mundane
in Inventions but luxury is ALS is and
the father to um real freedom to
consider bold new ideas and I really do
believe that in part um we we need to
recognize that we pissed people off in
the early 90s and we need to reestablish
trust and we have the basis to do it I
made that point to Barry barish that had
the SSC not been cancelled by the
venality of my fellow physicists he
would not have won the Nobel Prize that
he left on the couch here uh because he
only joined eligo because the SS was
cancelled and then furthermore uh the
higs boan which was the primary
discovery of the Large Hadron Collider
resulted in two Nobel prizes uh but not
to any of the experimentalists and I
wonder you guys are are theorists what I
I made this joke with Eric he always
hits me when we're in person when I but
I say like you know do you really think
of experimentalists as like you know the
joke is what do you call someone who
hangs out with musicians well you call
them a a drummer what do you call
someone who hangs out with physicist an
experimentalist back in the 1900s people
used to say that Einstein was practicing
Jewish physics he was doing theoretical
physics real men did Aryan physics that
was experimental physics oh how times
have changed there's a few Jews who have
won the Nobel Prize and some of whom are
fellow experimentalists uh like Ray
Weiss like Barry barish and others but
the question is uh what you know to what
extent do you feel like there is a you
know a um a difference of of view
Viewpoint as to the importance of
experimental scientists versus I I mean
I don't think someone you know Bine
looked at the equations of quantum
mechanics and said let me invent the
transistor which will then power all
these cell phones I I I feel like a lot
of these discoveries are serendipitous
uh in theory it's kind of naturally
serendipitous whereas experimentalist we
kind of need to know what we're looking
for before we set out what do you think
of the difference between theoretical
physics experimental physics Max uh
first and then Eric uh in terms of the
difference and similarities that they
may engender
I I think experimentalist experimental
physicists and theoretical physicists
have always had a a LoveHate
relationship with one another uh
where deep down there was a very deep
respect both ways and it's been a very
very healthy relationship as well where
experimentalists have U discovered new
things which po po posed mysteries for
theorists to chew on and and theorists
have sometimes taken giant leaps
of and and and motivated experiments
that wouldn't otherwise have done it's
quite obvious to me that if you had if
you eliminated either theoretical
physics or experimental physics the
field as a whole would have gone almost
nowhere I think you know Brian there are
three sort of categories of experiments
experiments that I don't particularly
exciting but I'm glad somebody did them
then there's experiments like the Cobalt
60 experiment that showed that the
Universe was left right asymmetric where
the effect is so astounding and the and
the courage needed to say I believe that
this crazy suggestion is worth trying um
where I admire the courage as well as
the skill and the establishing it is so
profound that um I I think it's you know
top level stuff and then there's like
weird stuff I remember I think the Nobel
Prize for the
um discovery of the particles or the
fields that communicate the weak force
or the w and z particles I remember the
description of stochastic cooling I
think which was what Simon vmir had had
contributed where it was like we're
going to take a box where there are
particles bouncing around and we're
going to keep nudging the Box in precise
ways so that it absorbs the energy from
the individual particles and so that
they will all get cooled by virtue of
the fact that we can nudge this thing I
mean it was the most mindblowing
description and part of what I hope to
be helping Brian do is to distinguish
that there's an experiment that has to
be done it was done we're happy that it
happened there was an experiment that
showed something absolutely astounding
it's it's a different sort of of a thing
which took courage and then there's
experiments that look like theoretical
physics but are even better sometimes
because they're actually physically
manifested uh like stochastic Cooling
and in part I think that when we call it
experiment we're not doing enough to
talk about the taxonomy of different
things that us theoretically minded
people find amazing about what the guys
who actually get in gals who get you
know down and dirty uh doing the actual
nuts and bolts soldering and
gluing yeah when you think about though
you know who does a scientist if you say
the word scientist uh to an individual
they'll think of Stephen Hawking Albert
Einstein Carl Sean it's rare if anybody
Richard Fineman they don't think about
experimentalist and yet uh you know
something like in my book losing the
Nobel Prize I make this point like 70%
of Nobel prizes have gone to
experimentalist since 1940 and from my
perspective you know we need the kind of
Bri greens Max tegmark Eric Weinstein's
of experimental physics to communicate
how freaking cool it is because you can
actually get something done in a day and
as as Albert Einstein sorry Albert
Michaelson the first one of the first
Americans to win the Nobel Prize he said
that experiments are like Puzzles the
more you do the better you get and every
time you do a puzzle it's like the
Rubik's Cube uh I'm trying to get the
inventor of the Rubik's Cube on my
podcast I'll let you know if I can get
that done but cin vafa uh you're a
mutual friend of you guys he was on the
show he wrote a book called puzzles to
un unlock the universe unravel the
universe and I asked him what do you
what would you rather solve a mystery or
a puzzle and it was a question I asked
Freeman Dyson the late great Freeman
Dyson on this very show as well what it
animates you guys is it the puzzle
solving that I like to do like working
on my car building a telescope where I
know there's a solution maybe I'm not a
good enough experimentalist to get it
done but someone is good better than me
can get it done or a mystery that
perhaps has no answer Max let's start
with you what do you prefer most in life
Mysteries that may not be solvable or
puzzles which have a solution that you
can
complete I love both I mean not it not
being solvable doesn't phase me I'd much
rather have uh any questions I can't
answer than answers I can't question
we're gonna go there on God in a minute
but keep going yeah that is actually
very much my Mantra as a scientist I I
also feel that um the whole distinction
between experimentalist and physicist
experimentalist in slip is kind of
uh outdated and dissolving first of all
you have a lot of people who uh work at
the interface like phenomenologists who
try to connect the two then you have
people like me I spent five years
building a radio telescope and I spent a
lot of time working with you and others
on experimental data but I'm mostly a
theorist and then you have entirely
new different areas which are neither
experiment or theory in a strong
astronomy right they're very astronomers
are very clear to say I am an observer
not an
experimentalist and uh in now we have a
new field computational physics which
clearly is here with us to stay you know
if someone writes if someone devotes 10
years of their career to do amazing
supercomputer simulations and developing
new algorithms for Lattis qcd with a
goal ultimately of of computing the
whole periodic table from first
principles right that's not
Theory it's not
experiment it's a little bit like being
an observer Where You observe inside
your it's it's frankly a new field so I
think uh we probably better off not
obsessing too much about artificial
boundaries between are you this kind of
physicist or that kind of physicist also
I should say before Eric you respond but
uh I would say that experimentalists
don't have to be able to create new
theories but we better
understand the theories that others have
proposed well enough that we can make
beautiful experiments you know our
friend Sabina Hassen Felder she says you
know beauty is driving physics astray I
disagree with her vehemently when she
came on my interview because I said all
experiments are beautiful even the ugly
you know chicklet and chewing gum and
coat hanger ones because they're all
teasing out something that is going to
reveal something about the universe
whether it's be through a null result as
I'm used used to coming up with uh or an
actual positive detection these
experiments have to have a certain
symmetry Beauty and naturalness about
them in order to succeed Eric what do
you think about the uh this this you
know rather provocative I think Brian
you've been on this and and uh you've
actually been very influential in the
evolution of my thinking about this I
hadn't realized the extent to which the
theorists i' I've been so focused on the
fact that we seem to have appointed
about six or seven people to talk to the
public on behalf of all physics that I
was sort of not realizing that all of
them tend to come from the theory camp
and they all tend to come with varying
amounts of gwiz which is partially good
and partially not good I'm not entirely
against woo and G whiz but you need to
do it in the right proportion I think
partially what it has to do with is the
shock if you know um for those of us who
program computers now and again
sometimes you'll have a theor a theory
and then you'll instantiate it inside of
the computer and when the graphic
actually shows you what your equations
have been saying you have this kind of
surprise you may have written the code
you may have come up with the equations
you may have designed everything but the
computer reflects you back to you and
you're like whoa it works it's real I
mean I think I was maybe almost the
first I think I may have been the first
person to actually draw inside of a
computer a three-dimensional model of
parallel translation that applies um in
economics and when I saw it come up I
was just astounded
and I think it has a different Beauty to
it I wish more theorists were doing some
experiment more experimentalists and let
me say the negative thing for the
experimentalist you guys cannot afford
to be so light on the theory if you're
going to actually check our work you
need to speak the language of people
whose work you're I'm very worried that
there's going to be a translation error
and you're going to think that you're
understanding what we're talking about
with tensors and differential forms and
bundles but in fact we need people who
go back and forth so I'm worried about
the two cultures of CP snow dividing
experimentalists from theorists and in
part that's on the experimentalist
they're they're trying to get by with
Antiquated language as if uh you know
tensors are still things uh collections
of numbers that transform according to
rules which is not a good way of
describing them in the slightest um with
that said I think that there are a small
number of very interesting places where
you see something that sounds like a
theory that's actually experimental if
you look at Watson and cric's um
discovery of the three-dimensional
structure of the double helix they went
through a triple helix that they built a
model of which was an embarrassment to
them they also went to a situation in
which um they come up with the double
helix after the the parts are machined
and delivered to their to their uh the
room in which they're working in some
sense the double helix was an
experimental result and if I can pick
out on another one in the late 50s there
was this really anomalous thing which I
still can't quite figure out you guys
can inform me the bow Aronoff effect was
the last really significant Discovery
around plain old classical sort of
electromagnetism now there may be a beam
and and some Quantum interference and
stuff like that but we didn't understand
that the electromagnetic field strength
which we thought was the real object is
not really the primary object and the
real primary object is something called
a vector potential when it turned out
that we had gotten to the late 50s
without even understanding the most
beautiful of our classical field
theories in its
totality it indicated to me that um what
is the danger of having the strict
division of labor in the pin Factory of
science where you don't have enough
people who are able to go back and forth
and I really look back to those guys
like
fmy uh you know who were great
calculators beta who is a great
calculator people who did both of these
things and at a minimum we need to be um
getting these people in the same rooms
and I have to be honest with you there's
a way in which I think theory has gone
into a worse Direction even though I'm
closer to it because there's been so
little in fundamental physics that's
been propelling Theory forward except at
the level of the framework so we now
have a much better idea of the framework
of the theory we haven't been idle but
we found very little that's profoundly
new coming from the theory side since
the standard model was put into rough uh
final form uh as it stayed since in the
early 70s and Max what do you make of
the fact that you know everyone sort of
uh sacrifices themselves as Lenny suskin
calls it at they become poer AI you know
they become overwhelmed by this uh this
notion of fals viability first proposed
in the demarcation criteria of Carl
popper great philosopher I haven't I've
told this to Eric but I want to say it
to you I feel we physicists have math
Envy you know Freud called you know most
people having certain other kinds of eny
people talk about physics Envy but
actually I think we have math Envy as
physicist because at least
mathematicians know that there are
formal limitations in the uh consistency
of their mathematical formalisms in
physics we're left with popper is just
like falsifiability and I've made this
case many times with only with Nobel
Prize winners because I I feel like
their reputation is so Stellar but but
then many of them don't want to you know
risk losing their the sheen on their
gilded Graven image of Alfred Nobel but
anyway I want to ask you uh the fact
that there's so much attention given to
wormholes given to Black Hole
singularities given to the Big Bang
itself given to your favorite one of
your favorite subjects the Multiverse is
this why you're going into like more
kind of hardcore or practical or
experimental science because we can't
ever see any of those things let alone
know that they're real so why is it that
you know that there's so many physicists
that are overwhelmed with the notion of
popper but yet are practicing and
appealing to the public the G isz Mind
Of God is inside the singular you know
why why is
that I guess there's a spectrum of
questions in there one of them is poer
yay or nay I promise to address that yes
a separate question is where do we draw
the line between science on one hand and
[__] on on the other
yes and
um
I would first of all say so I'm going to
say something which might sound
paradoxical I'm going to defend poer but
attack a lot of the people who claim
that uh in talking about black hole
interiors and multi Multiverse are
[__] and
and saying they misunderstood POA so
what POA says is that you know if if I
if I tell you about a theory and you say
Max give me one possible experiment that
could prove you wrong and I can't come
up with anything then this is the
scientific theory I stand by that I
think that's perfectly fair and
um in fact there was a fascinating
debate about Evolution once between Bill
NY and someone else and Bill NY asked
the other guy if he could name one thing
that would persuade him that creationism
was wrong and he couldn't so so there
poer would come down on on Bill ny's
side that said though I still
think many people have misunderstood
poer and can a wake too crude view on it
what we what we test in science are
theories so for example if you have an
argument you and Eric about what's
really happening inside of a black hole
you can never go there and measure it
and then come back and do a podcast
about it right does that mean it's all
Bs no it does not mean that what you're
actually testing instead is whether
general
relativity is correct as it stands
because general relativity predicts a
lot of things you can never test
directly with experiment like exactly
what happens inside the Event Horizon
but also predicts a lot of things you
can test like the perihelion shift of
mercury like the bending of Starlight by
the sun like like the hul Taylor Pulsar
like the expanding universe and and so
many other things that we study with
great Precision right now including
again the patterns on your beach ball
behind you there the micro background
right and in so in science we have the
situation that if you have you can you
cannot dismiss general relativity as
being unscientific BS because it is
testable so if you if you fail many
times to falsify it poer style then you
have to start taking seriously all its
predictions even its addictions that you
cannot directly experimentally test like
what happens inside of black holes and
this is exactly the mistake I think
people make now analogously in other
areas they'll take for example Alan gu
Andre Lind and others theory of
inflation and they will acknowledge this
is a scientific theory because it makes
a lot of predictions it makes some
predictions even for the micro
background it's had many chances they
get falsified and it's survived so far
so we have to start taking seriously
also some of its other predictions we
cannot test which is that space goes on
far beyond that beach ball probably so
far beyond that it's worth calling other
regions parallel universes for instance
uh
so is that non-scientific no it's not
inflation is a scientific
theory and a scientific theory you take
it or leave it it's all or nothing you
cannot say oh you can go into Starbucks
and say yeah I want this coffee but
without the caffeine in it that's fine
but you cannot say I want general
relativity I'm just going to opt out of
the black hole
prediction yeah I'm in such a different
place I think I I fear that I'm G to
just put my my foot in it but I'm GNA
fall back on my wingman dck I don't know
if you guys have heard of him
um he says uh a couple of things that
are widely quoted uh it is more
important to have Beauty in one's
equations than to have them fit
experiment
now that's clearly the sound of of a
crazy person in some sense
um the the um he he goes on to say if
there is not complete agreement between
the results of one's work in experiment
one should not allow oneself to be too
discouraged so why is this well it's
because he lived this and one of the
things that I'm really against is the
promotion of the sanitized version of
science with the scientific method and
popper
uh not coming remotely close to how
science is actually done so we we so
like Max just talked about the anomalous
uh procession of the parhelion of
mercury um the problem is if I recall
correctly when Einstein first formulated
this he formulated it with Grossman in
1913 and then he reformulated it alone
and put some specificity to it in a
weird way the 1913 thing was better than
his first go at being concrete because
he said the reachi tensor is equal to
the to the stuff in the
universe and that equation doesn't even
make sense because it's not it doesn't
have a particular
um equation that it has to satisfy work
out but it was good enough if I recall
correctly to explain the process the
anomalous procession as a result you can
have a wrong theory that works with
experiment and then you can have the
reverse situation which is uh
where um derac was really getting this
he says I might tell you the story I
learned from Schrodinger of how when he
first got the idea for his equation the
one that Max Held up he immediately
applied it to the behavior of the
electron and the hydrogen atom that is
the simplest possible system and he got
results that did not agree with the
experiment this disagreement arose
because at the time it was not known
that the electron has a spin and that of
course was a great disappointment to
stroer and it caused him to abandon the
work for months then he noticed that if
he applied the theory in a more
appropriate way not take taking into
account the refinements required by uh
relativity to this rough approximation
his work was in agreement with the
experiment he published this first paper
he goes on to say that this wrong
equation that Max Held up is not in fact
the equation shoner had to begin with
which is now called the Klein Gordon
equation so he didn't have the derac
equation which is relativistic or the
Klein Gordon he came up with a wrong
equation it's called the Klein Gordon
equation because it was invented by
shinger and I it pains me to admit this
because kle was in Sweden
but but the point that I'm trying to get
at here is you can have situations where
you get agreement with experiment your
theory is wrong you can have other
situations where your theory is right
but in a stupid way you don't have the
instantiation right and the message that
I want to send which is of course going
to be treated as heresy by all of the U
people who are you know this this the
the people who have this energy that
there is a demarcation problem that you
can solve at the skep our skeptic
friends and our rationalist friends no
that's not how this game works the real
way this works is that the true
scientific method right the scientific
method is the radio edit of great
science and the way the great science
works is Every Which Way humans have
ever come up with reliable understanding
of their environment and their world
which may include dreams it may include
taking LSD in the case of Carrie Mullis
I don't know it it involves so many
weird crazy things that I'm I'm just I
guess I'm sort of sad that we keep
trying to uh neuter and and and and
emasculate this subject when in fact
it's the messiness and the fact that you
don't know whether agreement with
experiment is a death Nell or or in fact
it's a false indication that you're on
on the right path I think that we just
need to grow up and grow out of both uh
emphatic paparian ISM usually misin
because poer wasn't as dumb as people
claim and we also have to stop stop
fetishizing the scientific method um
when we have the culis of the world
running around figuring out
Benzene uh you know so many weird things
contribute to our uh understanding of a
reliable information in science we've
got to be more honest that there is no
such thing as the scientific method the
way you learn about it in school yeah I
I think the way taught in school is is
frankly kind of silly uh the way I see
it
my first postdoc Mentor yor
grael once said something that's always
stuck with me which is it's better to be
wrong in an interesting way than to be
right in a boring way so for example
shorting is first failed hydrogen atom
you know Einstein's first failed general
relativity formulation they were wrong
in an interesting way and being wrong in
an interesting way is very very valuable
for physics yeah uh second I feel and I
thought that was a bit of the sentiment
of what you were saying there Eric is
you know humility is has to be at the
core of of science right not only should
we be humble and acknowledge that
everything we believe in might be wrong
even our P pet theory that we just
published but we should actively seek
out ways in which we can actually be
proven wrong it's kind of the opposite
of a politician right who avoids saying
anything or put sticking your neck out
so that they can be proven wrong we
should aspire to to we should really
aspire to live dangerously we should
have the mindset that the more we force
ourselves to live dangerously and have
our theories potentially be proven wrong
right the more likely we are to learn
something interesting yeah so absolutely
just on that front if you think about
Paul lonus Pauling racing Watson and cck
for the double helix both of them came
up with a triple helix with a sugar
phosphate backbone on the interior with
the the nucleotides sticking out uh if I
recall correctly so there are certain
mistakes that may be canonical on our
way towards the truth and that you
actually have to go through the valley
of error in order to to to to scale the
peaks of success and insight and what is
absolutely important about this and it
goes back to the funding conversation
unfortunately is that you need to have a
tolerant enough community that people
can afford to tell the truth and
continue in their quests without worry
that by stumbling they will immediately
you know there's this old thing in the
in the concentration camps of of uh
death camps where if you coughed you
were gone and so you know at some level
this zero tolerance for error is
something that really bothers me a lot
of these great old stories people made
error after error after error on their
path to becoming the people who who who
put things in final for form and I think
part of what's going on is that the one
thing I'm going to quibble with I loved
what Max just said I think it was great
but I I do have a a caveat unfortunately
because I I think he's going to say it
better than than I can we have to stop
fetishizing
humility um because clearly this is not
a trait that most people associate with
the theoretical physics Community to say
the least what really is going on is
that physicists and great scientists
need to separate facilities they need
absolute pathological self-confidence
and arrogance you need to be able
apparently Eric Lander used to call in
like a hundred biologist mathematicians
and say tell me what's wrong with my
idea they would tell him what's wrong
with his idea he'd say thank you I was
worried that there was something really
wrong but none of you came up with it uh
you know so can can you tell a hundred
of the smartest people that you value
their opinion you're all wrong yes
that's absolutely important you have to
have the arrogance and you have to have
the humility which is what Max was
saying the real trick which we don't
explain to people is regulated
expression of arrogance and humility
just the way like with the operon the
pajama experiment sometimes you're
expressing something sometimes you're
repressing it and I really think that
the part of the problem is is that some
of the people who are incredibly modest
and Incredibly humble what we need to do
is to get them hyped up on their own
brilliance other people who are
insufferable and don't um really seem to
uh I think it's clear enough I think the
basic point is arrogant people need more
humility humble people often need more
self-confidence and we we can't keep
extoling one virtue over the other so on
that note I do want to take some
questions we've had uh couple hundred
dollars worth maybe even $1,000 dollar
worth which is going to go go to your
jents favorite Charities we're going to
split that down the middle uh I want to
thank uh people uh for asking these
wonderful questions let's do a couple of
quick ones and then I want to get into
uh a couple of topics that I'm
interested in just because how often do
I get to get my two good buddies
together in a council of the wise uh I
want to ask um first of all a question
about aliens which has com in from one
of my uh one of my listeners but I want
to twist it to something I'm interested
in that Max has thought about a lot
which is the so-called simulation
hypothesis I had on jel Tarter this this
uh uh past week or last week uh talking
about this signal from proximus and Tu
that was supposedly picked up she was
rather dubious about that uh but this
question of whether or not we exist as
the as the Life 2.0 and whether or not
Life 2.0 ever becomes fully like life
3.0 is my question and what are your
current thoughts Max about the
simulation hypothesis first maybe state
with B WM you know meant by this uh you
know you you've talked about this a lot
but how much credulity should we have in
this and then I'm going to ask Eric uh
about the ethics and the moral morality
of a simulatable uh civilization so and
what ways would they not be or be like
Gods first max simulation hypothesis
your thoughts current status all right
so let me first explain Bostrom
simulation argument and then explain why
I think it's flawed
okay so uh the basic
argument starts by saying well if if if
uh we're a blob of quirks and electrons
and our conscious minds are ultimately
all about information processing right
then surely if you were actually
simulated in computer so that the
information processing was exactly the
same maybe you're in suppose you were in
some future super Advanced Computer game
or whatever you wouldn't know the
difference of course so maybe we are in
a simulation uh and then Bostrom goes on
to say well in in this Universe of ours
uh it's likely that eventually
artificial intelligence will advance and
and we're going to help life spread into
much of our observable universe and
there's going to be massive amounts of
computations and
simulations and
perhaps way more simulated Minds than
real minds and therefore if your random
mind having these experiences you are
simulated so you are probably living in
a simulation he's more careful on that
and lists all the cost also so there's
nothing flawed with what he wrote but uh
I I think the the conclusion that we are
probably living in a simulation is
false and and to see where it starts to
go
wrong just note that suppose you buy it
and you say okay we are all in a
simulation now having this
conversation we can make the same
argument all over again that oh in our
simulated Universe there going to be all
these future doubly simulated minds and
there much more of them so we're
probably double simulated right and then
we can repeat and say actually no we're
triple oh quadruple oh we're simulated
Google Flex times no noxx FX times and
you start to get a sinking feeling that
there's something rotten
here and and there is yes the the big
mistake is that
the it doesn't matter at all how many
whether they're more simulated or real
Minds in in the the universe that we
think we're in what matters is what's
going on in the basement Universe right
where maybe there is the original
simulation and and if we're simulated we
have no clue what that universe is
actually like so we should have an open
mind about this as anything else I but I
would definitely not uh jump on the
badwagon and say oh we're all simulated
on the other hand if you're still
worried that maybe you are simulated the
conclusion is pretty obvious you should
live a really interesting life so that
the simulators don't get bored and shut
you down teg Mark's
wager an update of Pascal uh Eric what
are your thoughts about simulation
hypothesis is it uh valid and what if
any obligations would a master simulator
have to his Denison or her its Dennison
let's be
honest it's very interesting to me that
when we talk of so there's the
simulation hypothesis and also the Rogue
AI AGI hypothesis and we don't really
connect these so as the simulators we
are terrified of creating the gollum the
Frankenstein monster that comes after us
and uh and out competes us because we
are like ants to its Godlike
intelligence and on the other hand if we
are the simulated we're terribly
frightened that we are going to have the
plug pulled out which these are the same
stories in some sense but we're on both
sides of them and we're telling them
from the point of view of we're scared
in both cases I never hear us say is it
ethical to pull the
plug uh on the AGI because what are you
know what are are we do we have the
right to uh kill something off that may
intend to intend to kill us and uh what
are our obligations to this to the
simulators so I think that our
narcissism is clearly on display in the
simulation hypothesis I do think though
that in part what it does is it takes
the loss of religion that we associate
with n and the inability to construct
God and to reconstructed inside of the
one sector of the economy that still
seems to be behaving as if it does
didn't know that everything came
crashing down in the early 70s which is
the computation communication sector and
so weirdly like if you look at what's
happened in physics we've all moved
towards information you know maybe the
university is made of information well
it seems pretty clear that this has to
do with the fact that that Silicon
Valley or which is now evaporating and
reconstituting in Miami and Austin or
whatever um that that this Silicon
Valley ethos has pervaded our
philosophical thinking our scientific
thinking maybe it's an attempt to get
money out of Mark Zuckerberg it's
unclear but I do think that it's very
unlikely in my to my way of thinking
given the important of importance of the
calculus and therefore the Continuum in
most things that we do that it it would
be harder to simulate this world than to
build it and I think that that's one of
the reasons why I'm not very excited
about the simulation hypothesis because
the easiest way to simulate it is to
construct the actual thing that you're
simulating and I think in that framework
we just haven't thought uh enough about
it and when we're sort of reaching for
the most obvious uh hypothesis the last
thing I wanted to say is that if we
stopped calling it The simulation and
started calling it The effective Theory
we we we distinguish now thanks to you
guys in renormalization theory that
higher level theories that aren't true
we now call effective because they're
still useful we haven't dispensed with
Newton we just call him effective rather
than fundamental so we don't know what a
fundamental Theory actually looks like
but if you imagine that the classical
world is in some sense like a simulation
we have a Quantum existence and the
quantum existence is hidden from us and
we we stumble around as mesoscale
phenomena in this classical world that
doesn't really exist but kind of washes
out of the quantum uh if you wanted a
hypothesis I think that that would be
kind of a really interesting thing does
that get to you philosophically if it
doesn't excite you maybe the idea is
that you're really here for the science
fiction rather than the science I don't
know yeah that is uh something I've
thought about also yeah do we uh if we
right before we pull the plug on Max's
super AI simulator is going to scream
and what would that do to us is is it
like cooking lobsters which I I don't
know anything about that but uh Max do
you want to have a quick followup before
we start to wind down or are we good to
go with that sure
sure I think there there's been some
amount of self self-criticism uh here so
in that Spirit let's be honest we are
not that ethical as a species even
though we love patting ourselves on our
head and and pretending we are right we
um have done a lot of horrible things in
history and even today we're still not
that ethical right why why else is it
that we've talked so little about the
people who died of starvation in this
year of 2020 and of
tuberculosis then we have talked about
the fewer people who died of covid right
it's because those people were poor and
we didn't feel our ethics applied to
them as much as the Richer people who
who died of covid-19 that's the the sad
truth why do we talk so much less about
the suffering of factory farmed chickens
and pigs than than you know that we talk
about good-look actresses or whatever
it's because again we're not maybe as
ethical as we'd like to be but being
shifting a little bit to optimism I
think we should Aspire certain need to
be become more ethical and maybe uh and
I no I would say actually by far the
greatest ethical dilemma is what we're
going to make of the whole Cosmic future
because you know on one hand we have
enough technology now that we could
drive life on this we could drive
Humanity entirely extinct if we wanted
to which would perhaps wipe out you know
enormous amounts of positive experiences
in life for billions of years throughout
much of our universe right or we could
get our act together and and help life
spread from this planet and
flourish beyond the wildest dreams of
our ancestors for billions of years in
this amazing future and this to me is
the ultimate ethical dilemma what are we
going to do are we squander them going
to squander this future or are we going
to seize it and I would like to end with
with Freeman Dyson whom you just
mentioned here because he was not only
an intellectual hero of mine but it was
so inspiring that you know he would hang
out and have lunch with us lowly mortal
posts you know back when I lived in New
Jersey and and he used to point out that
look you know you ain't seen nothing yet
you know life today in our universe as
far as we can tell is still this this
puny peration on what looks mostly dead
right and uh yet intelligence has this
power to completely transform the
physical world look whatti intelligence
has transformed Earth since it showed up
it's and with artificial intelligence it
could even happen quite soon that much
of what we see out there starts to come
alive and and our universe starts to
really wake up and and fulfill its
potential
I I find it incredibly inspiring to
think about how we here In Our Lifetime
on our little spinning ball in space you
know actually have so much influence
over the whole future of ethics and and
yeah positive experiences in the cosmos
maybe and that's the reason honestly
honestly that I spend so much of my time
on the future Life Institute and and
other efforts to try to make sure that
we steer the technology towards making
the future awesome Max let me just ask
you one question question about that
assuming that Einstein more or less
holds into whatever the fundamental
theory is and that the constraints that
we've come to live with under
einsteinian relativity like the speed of
light yeah um continue to hold and
assume that uh humans have to live under
that do you think given how far other
good stuff is away from us that
realistically we are going to be able to
figure out any way of bootstrapping our
waist someplace interesting out of our
relatively isolated solar system with
very few habitable
surfaces yes absolutely I actually
geeked out on that in a big way in
chapter six of my book life 3.0 where I
I just asked the question what if we
shift from
being having our technology limited by
our own um intelligence to instead
having our technology limited by the
laws of physics how much better could we
do and yes you're you're completely
right there's still limits presumably
there's still a speed limit speed of
light etc etc and because of dark energy
there's a limit to how many atoms we can
ever access out there but the limits are
just mind blowingly far above what we
have now right so first of all going to
other solar systems as a walk in the
park with our artificial intelligence
going to other galaxies is also work in
the park you can uh and I put I had a
lot of fun making just some nerdy plots
just to see you know how how much of our
Cosmos can we actually get to there are
galaxies that you can see right now at
very high red shift where sadly if our
current understanding of cosmology is
true it's it's all C but not touch
because they they're going away from us
so fast at an accelerating rate that no
technology will get us there but um a
significant fraction of the beach ball
behind the Brian keing is in place for
us and I would really hate it if our
Earth origin life spends its entire
future just on this little spinning ball
I can't stand to think about it and the
re I I can't I personally want to get
off of this and and visit the
neighborhood but my feeling about this
is that I'm hoping against hope that we
have a way of going against Einstein and
I have to say that even now I I can go
against many many people but if it's dck
and Einstein I really really don't like
it um but thanks thanks for that answer
yeah well guys this has been just a
thrilling thing for me I always say on
my channel you know Sam Harris has this
thought experiment you know if you could
go into a chamber and there was a button
you could push and it would instantly
teleport you to Mars and You'd Survive
and come back and the only catch is
right before you push it they have to
kill you so you don't have uh two copies
of Brian keing lying around uh would you
push that button and a lot of people
would uh and uh you know I thought about
and I said you know what actually I have
that ability to teleport right now and
it's called my children and not only my
children uh but a biological nature uh
but also my ideological children those
that I influence and I want to just
thank you two for being uh influences to
me uh ideological uh I'll call you guys
cousins because you're not that much
older than me if if so at all but uh I
want to thank you guys for going into
the impossible it's now champagne
o'clock where Max lives actually I've
been on champagne this whole day uh
already since the crack of 8 I want to
just remind people go and look at
improvethe news.org it is one of the
most fun and delightful pieces of
actionable uh intelligence that you can
use to make 2021 a better year than 2020
I had so much fun with it uh please go
to Eric Weinstein's Channel on YouTube
and also subscribe to the portal please
uh stay tuned for this to this channel
we're going to have uh deac Chopra in
conversation with Frank Wich facilitated
by me uh that was pretty fun and uh I'm
going to have both of them individually
as well as well as John presal is coming
up not too uh long from now and I had
giant narar who is a giant of cosmology
as Max will know was one of the fathers
of the steady state universe and I think
it's important to listen to our elders
as I've listened to you guys who are
barely older than me in this universe
please like And subscribe to the Brian
ke Dr Brian keing YouTube channel also
into the possible on iTunes wherever you
get it the portal Max teag marks
Universe it's one of the most delightful
places in this corner of the Multiverse
and now I can say with quite a good deal
of confidence that I'm closer to knowing
the mind of God thank you boys happy
2021 shatova everybody out there I wish
it be a he healthy happy safe uh new
year for
everybody sha thanks for having us thank
you and
got
indeed it will be bye guys